[Music] [Applause]
foreign
look at this pretty hair kids oh [__] dressed up
for [__] fat man beyond welcome to fat man
beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernardin hey
uh if you're wondering why this uh is because I
literally just came from a photo shoot a Jay and
Silent Bob photo shoot and uh that's why I may
look made up as well uh I don't normally make
myself up nor do I [__] normally look at that
kids it's that simple there there's your childhood
[__] lies nothing but lies I was just talking
to my friend before about um I don't know if I'm
supposed to say this yet there's a well [__] it
there's a um a muppet show that's coming to Disney
plus uh I'm up in Mayhem called Muppet Mayhem very
good uh from Adam Goldberg and I may or may not
have been on set and whatnot but I was talking
about how being around The Muppets um was like
you know I'm [__] now a hardened professional in
this here entertainment business and you know I've
met [__] famous people and [__] like that
Legends and but you know once you know how the
sausage is made maybe the magic loses a little
bit of its flavor but I was reduced to [__]
childhood when I was on set with Muppets because
it's still it's not like animation where it's just
like you know oh my God [__] I love these
characters and they're like well then you'll
see them in nine months to a year because that's
how long it takes when you're with the Muppets
they they are alive the moment a hand goes up
the ass and most of these cats have been doing
it for like ever keep them on so like you'll be
having a conversation with the person who works
the Muppet but they keep the Muppet going so
like you're talking to a human and the Muppets
alive in the conversation you keep like I'm not
even talking about when they have the Muppet talk
to you you're just talking to the muppeteer and
they're still doing this [__] looking around and
you feel like there's a third party that you're
having a conversation with and it's absolutely
[__] magical like and and so low Tech you're
talking about one of the oldest art forms on the
planet right like [__] a puppet For Heaven's
Sake but my god it works like [__] crazy man
um hopefully it's not lost on The Tick Tock
generation I hope them up and still have as
much [__] Magic for like a kid today as they did
for us do you think do you think they do Mark you
know I I'm not sure I I remember feeling very kind
of old and crestfallen when the Muppets and Sesame
Street moved to HBO which they did for a while and
like I felt like no they're still there yeah like
I felt like you could find the episodes that got
rid of half the episodes or some sort of [__]
yeah I I felt as if we failed them like they
were giving us a public good and all we had to
do was once a year buy a [__] tote bag and we
didn't buy enough [__] tote bags and suddenly
they needed the patronage of daddy Warner Brothers
to make the Muppets go and he's like what it was
free it was a public good it was ours anybody
could watch it it would make me cry and yeah we
didn't just get enough shitty [__] umbrellas
from the Helena Rubenstein Foundation to make
Rubinstein Foundation um kids we're old men
talking about old men [__] the moment you
hear a [__] middle-aged man talking about
how we failed The Muppets you know that we're
buggy you're watching Batman Beyond kids welcome
back it's been a red hot minute last time we did
this we were live at spod Castle Baxter Ides
of Markham what a [__] great time that was
um but since then so many things have
happened tell them where you went I was
in New Orleans for the Overlook Film Festival
um showing a little picture called splinter
um which was what a wonderful experience that
was um I mean we played the pan-african film
festival here in La which was great but I always
feel like film festivals in your hometown are a
bit like Comic Cons in your hometown which is
it's not quite as special because it's not a
destination like you don't go to that place and
invest in that place for three or four days you
go home every night right um but going to overlook
which is all about horror and all about genre and
it being in New Orleans and New Orleans being a
spooky [__] City anyway um it was just so much
fun and it was so supportive and everybody there
was really welcoming to the short they had nothing
but lovely things to say about it and uh and
it was just it was great and spending four days
in New Orleans is automatically a good time uh
Tiffany our dear friend uh Tiffany Smith who was
there with you indeed sent uh photos and [__]
I couldn't get information out of [__] Mark
he was busy being a [__] celebrity director and
[__] but Tiffany was like uh she was texting me
being like greetings from from New Orleans
and stuff the picture her Mark I was like
oh my God how to play she said through the
roof and then she sent a picture of like a
[__] packed house watching a movie and stuff
now when we did fat man beyond its mod Castle
after the show was over Mark showed it and
[__] and one of my favorite moments in
smog Castle thus far um has been for those of
you who are like what the [__] is podcast
that's the movie theater smart Castle Cinemas
that I own with my friends back in Jersey
um one of my favorite moments that has happened
at the theater since we took it over in October
didn't even involve me it was sitting in the back
of the theater and cucking out on Mark while he
was up doing a q a that just wouldn't end it went
on for like an hour and the time we started the
movie it was like [__] almost been I think we
were we went to midnight or past midnight but
like people had great questions and [__] Mark
was holding court and answer him and [__] and
I was like oh that's my man right up there it was
so sweet and normally like you know I'm a man who
appreciates q a it's like how I made my bones in
this business but watching somebody else Ascend
with q a was in my own theater was wonderful how
was the Q and A's in uh New Orleans as they say
um I mean they were good but when you're part
of a shorts program which we were they just
um everybody is up there as part of the Q a so
it's like me and the Splinter team and then the
writer directors of the other five or six shorts
that are there so it's less an intensive hour long
um sort of Investigation of a movie and more just
kind of a glistening off the surface kind of chat
uh a round table as it were with a bunch of other
people which was still great because earlier the
shorts were really interesting and very well done
and all the other filmmakers were super great
um and smart and sharp and funny and and now
it's lovely man like there was no part of it that
wasn't a good time and every shorts block we were
in it sold out oh [__] hey well done yeah I'm
not gonna say it's our fault but it's our fault
did it you made it happen the um in uh uh chat
uh long story short uh Austin uh Harley's
boyfriend who was in Clark's three played uh
um blockchain Coltrane um
I was over my kid's house
that's right my kid has a [__] house if that
don't make you feel [__] old um and my kid like
[__] lives on YouTube on her big on her TV I was
gonna say big TV but it's not as big as my TV but
on her TV she don't [__] with it on her phone
or her laptop that's what she watches she don't
watch television and [__] she watches YouTube
on her TV and her favorite thing in the world that
runs constantly on [__] a never-ending Loop
are videos of people walking around Disneyland
there's a whole [__] sub Market of this [__]
including Peter sharetta who runs slash film and
has like creative slash film ran it for [__]
years Peter schrad is the one that took me to see
uh The Dark Knight for a press screening [__]
like when the Dark Knight came out and [__]
but Peter schrett has got a side hustle I don't
even know about where him and his lady just [__]
go to Disney and make videos all the time about
[__] things at Disney they're massive Disney
fans so my kid like I remember at one point
like she was I was like Woody why are you
always on YouTube and she showed me she's like
I love these videos and I was like I know that
[__] man that's the guy to run slash home she
goes no that's the guy who does whatever [__]
it's called whatever her show is and this is
what the kid lives for is these [__] videos
of people that go to Disneyland and literally
just shoot the entire experience like we watched
one video where guys like this is Indiana Jones
from [__] years ago this is the Indiana Jones
ride with a new paint job and like goes through
the whole ride holding the [__] camera walks
through the whole park she was watching a series
of videos of like Toontown they reopened and
[__] did new things to it and [__] so anyway
we watched you know I was like hey man if you're
gonna put if you're gonna watch something on
YouTube what about your old man and [__] like
that and she's like what do you mean I'm like I
can't believe I got a kid don't even know I'm on
[__] I said I do [__] show all the time and
it was right after we had done the live show from
smodcastle so I said [__] here give me that
and I [__] typed in our show and Austin her
boyfriend was a big YouTuber back in the day
and [__] like he just lived for that [__]
so he was like oh my God look at how many [__]
views you have and you don't you're not [__]
monetizing it correctly you don't even have super
chat I was like what's that and so he went in and
changed all the [__] settings and [__] and put
us up on Super Chat which Super Chat is apparently
people like can [__] give money to ask questions
and [__] so long story short will Wilkins who
uh of course is dilf man Banff man won't be with
us today because Banff man is in the UK going to
Celebration right now but we got a special report
from Bam Bam which we'll get to in a minute uh
dilfman will Wilkins who took over you know when
when uh JC couldn't do a show before is doing
the the show today jump on in here dilf man and
he [__] put a bucket what's up dilf man hello
um thank you for that [__] dollar my
friend yeah oh that was a dude who just
asked a ten dollar question why talking to
the one dollar again where's the ten dollar
question I'm sure if you scroll back through
it you'll see oh you're gonna be close oh my
God Joshua Mundo yeah Kevin did you receive a
delivery Friday that was not for Jen's birthday
was it flowers if so yes a gigantic [__] bouquet
of flowers that I had to explain to my wife
was not from like she was like who are you [__]
and I was like I'm not [__] Josh mundle I swear
if that was it it was for me and my mom thank you
my mom's in the hospital right now so if that's
what it is yes and then he said Mark did you go to
Ricardo's dookie chases or Floyd's to eat while in
New Orleans to answer his question because he
paid [__] nine bucks 10 bucks so I must ask
a question and I feel like this is somehow this
is going to be the end of the show as we know it
like suddenly we're building like an aristocracy
suddenly there's a one percent of question askers
exactly Mark and so it's no longer just a like
I asked a good question I'm in the feed they'll
notice and I was like excuse me sir here's my
shiny ten dollar piece for these gentlemen never
mind the rebel I want to know something first
anyway Joshua I did not eat in any of those places
um I went to coops uh coops bar in uh in in
the quarter I went to Parkway for uh my Po Boys
um and then I kind of like and of course
I went to to um Kevin demand for beignets
but other than that it was a little bit
catches to catch Canada the festival had
me moving so I didn't get a chance to kind of
wallow in the French Quarter as I usually do
uh Bijou who did not pay for a Super Chat question
so just to prove to you that we're still dealing
with the plebes as well kids we're not like [__]
icing anybody yeah but Bijou said super chat but
YouTube takes 30 of every contribution so we're
never going to get rich doing this [__] show
never ever ever so Austin God bless him
he thought this would change everything
is bricks goes here's ten dollars dance monkey
dick damn skippy I don't give a [__] how many
years I've been working in entertainment and
[__] or if I were for Netflix or not 10 bucks
is still [__] 10 bucks I grew up in an era where
10 bucks was like everything I'm a 70s kid so if
somebody throws me 10 [__] bucks you better damn
skippy they're gonna be I'm gonna be like this way
uh sir like trust me Logan I still appreciate the
value of a book in any event Super Chat is on if
you're into that [__] believe me you don't
have to Super Chat us and stuff [__] Daddy
Warbucks roll it in go buy me a fine fat man to
me this question I love the mixture of [__] two
childhood Classics of Dickens and any any itself
Daddy Warbucks um kids this is fat man beyond and
we haven't done it in a month so you'll excuse
our [__] excitement I guess not fight a month
I guess we did it Ides of March was Mark was the
15th 16th I think we did it on the 17th so it's
only April 10th so we missed it by a week being
a month between shows but as you heard with good
reason Mark at one point was in New Orleans did
you [__] with that spooky house that they had
in American Horror Story That's like ice country
right there I do not [__] with spooky houses
man like they had a whole like immersive kind
of experience where even like going to this
hotel room and do this thing and have a seance and
whatever it's like nope I'm good I don't I don't
need I don't I don't have a good time getting
scared so and I don't want to be scared in real
life so like I went with one person it wasn't
even an escape room it was some like slightly
immersive thing and I just spent the entire 20
minutes looking for the seams so that I could
be like all right this isn't real this isn't
real I don't have to punch anybody that's fine
because if somebody [__] touches me in a dark
hotel room I'ma punch him so like the people
pay good [__] money get touched in a dark hotel
room man you're just looking to give towards them
out holy [__] [__] all that we got pounds bro
pound sterling man Lewis Burridge says I give you
my shiny money and ask how Splinter is going down
can't wait to see it answer that man's question
mark he gave us 10 [__] pounds that's got to be
worth like a hundred dollars American I just gotta
say I agree with Mark this is not a good thing
it's automatically got off their manuals it'll
be we'll do this for one week and then probably
never again but still nothing's happening the
floor is yours Lewis Burridge sir Louis I'll tell
you uh the Splinter is going down very very well
incredibly smooth um we are at the point now
where I think we are going to finally fulfill
all of our Kickstarter obligations and send the
short to everybody who helped us make the short
um you know we we wanted to give the the
festival sort of space it's time to to have
it exclusively we've done so um we're going to be
hopefully fingers crossed bringing to Comic-Con
um so if any anybody is a Comic-Con want to see
if they can do so and if that's the case then
yeah like it's time to just [__] drop the
link in some emails and let the 2700 people
who helped us make it finally see what they paid
for now what can they [__] like throw that up
on YouTube or no uh it'll probably be via Vimeo a
little bit more protected than uh than YouTube is
that was my question even though here we are on
YouTube we're talking about how unsafe it ain't
unsafe anymore we got pound sterling answer your
question oh bro they're stacking up like Jets here
man there's a 15 question that's a 20 question
9.99 another one but hey the [__] man no I'm
kidding well all questions about while we're here
uh Twisted films you're right this is the end of
the [__] show for 15 [__] bucks man I'm trying
to win the lottery so I can hire you and Mark to
help me make my Tom Waits based movie think
Stand By Me but with Tom Waits and red Sabine
I went silent because of [__] red Sabine I mean
look we all love Tom Waits and [__] but like
red Sabine who talks about Red Sovine this day
and age films I hope you [__] get that money
because I know two dudes that'll help you out uh
20 question from Nick X Dillinger says I open my
wallet please open your dot dot dot mouth [__]
whatever you want man you asked a 20 question Nick
that's [__] real money and [__] uh Dart
car for 11 bucks says Hey guys love the show
how did Ezra and thrawn survive the jump into
hyperspace with the windows blown out what a
good question I mean [__] we're going to talk
about celebration and we're going to talk about
that Ahsoka trailer which essentially
looks like Rebels part two and [__]
um how I don't know I don't even know how to
answer that question bro somebody just asked a
49 question what the [__] I mean [__] making
movies this is what I'm gonna do for the rest of
my life answer questions for money man [__]
this is the best thing that ever happened to
me ever I'll give a [__] if it is the end
of the show this is a good thing uh I don't
know how they escape but I bet you Mark has
a guess how did Ezra and thrawn survive the
jump in hyperspace with the windows blown out I
have no [__] idea I've never seen Rebels so I
yeah that's a legit answer right there my guess
the force there you go I mean it's smart let's
let's [__] find out what somebody wants to know
for 49 how the [__] does that happen I can't
even find there you are oh it's Josh mondall man
Kevin did you give Jay and Jordan the grogu outfit
gift oh [__] that's our boy who is at [__]
The Ides of Mark who was like if you show [__]
Excalibur on June 21st I'm there because that's
my birthday remember he was the one who was right
right up front she came all the way from Austin
he had signs to go the show he had signs he was
our Let's Make a Deal guy that's what it said in
the card the card that came with the flowers that
said I'm the Let's Make a Deal Sign guy and I was
going like the look did I buy Let's Make a Deal
sign now I'm putting it all together and [__]
I can't wait to get off the show so I can tell
my wife I know who those [__] flowers came from
and yes I am having an affair with him uh he came
all the way from [__] Austin to go to to uh
The Ides of Mark and he also went of course to
Fountain in Beyond The Lodge show but he had come
to see The Muppets when when I did the movies that
made me the bumpit movie and [__] and I wasn't
there because I was away something that I'll be
talking about in the near future and whatnot um
but yes did I give Jay and join the grogu outfit
gift absolutely I did oh my God Josh stop paying
money to ask answer ask questions like that that's
way too much money but thank you I feel like 79
[__] bucks Jesus man I feel like a cam girl
right this is so hot dude uh eleven dollars
what do you want to see yeah I'll show you
Ted I'm gonna [__] uh Ed gave us five pounds
[__] Sterling to say Kevin and Mark you make
me so happy you make me happy [__] uh DG gave me
four dollars and twenty cents 420 said enough said
class right there Gabriel Lopez for 20 bucks is
Kevin your thoughts on season three of Mando so
far love you and thanks for the inspiration um
I I'm honestly I've enjoyed it I know a lot of
folks have had issues and [__] like that
and they're like why isn't this show about
the Mandalorian anymore but I legit love that
one episode that was all about Dr Pershing
um and I do love Boca tan so I like that
they've been following her storyline and
whatnot we'll talk more about the Mandalorian
in a red hot minute and stuff but Gabriel Lopez
[__] a oh my God the prescription hipster
for 17 bucks is Hey Kevin what's going on
with Muse moose Jaws delayed till you are free or
canceled I mean [__] I hope it's not the latter
um yeah it's just been delayed honestly Lion's
gate the good folks that we've been in business
with you know they did our home video for Jay
and Sal and Bob reboot and they produced all
the [__] clerks three smart bless him Mark
you want to just go grab some food we can leave
him here doing this for a little while no no it's
cool we'll get to everybody I should stop looking
yeah stop super chatting us kids for a red hot
minute we have so much show to get to but they
Alliance gate was like what else you got and I
was like I want to do this movie called Moose
Jaws they're like what is it I says it's Jaws
but with a moose instead of a shark and they
were like how much is it I was like three million
bucks they're like we'll make five of them so I'm
like oh [__] so it's now just stacked up
like Jets waiting for me to get there man
I I think for sure we're gonna start the 4 30
movie which is the next book I want to direct
um we shoot it in my movie theater spot Castle
Cinemas um in the beginning of September after the
summer movie season is done looks like we're gonna
start shooting the movie like hopefully September
1st and [__] then there's another thing that
just happened today which I can't talk about which
came out of the [__] blue kids and I I didn't
even expect we'd ever make this movie but suddenly
it looks like oh [__] we are going to make this
movie I'll talk about that way down the road man
um so thank you prescription hipster uh God
damn it this is so [__] fun bonanista says
Uh Kevin are you and Muse going to continue the
father podcast yes we absolutely are what a great
question he's supposed to come over this week for
us to record an episode uh we've been he's been
more busy than me because Jay Muse became a [__]
father uh his second child uh Lucian was born like
two months ago or whatever [__] adorable [__]
kid and Muse is like one of the most adventurous
fathers I ever saw he holds the kid in his palm
on his arm he goes look at this he goes like this
[__] and I hate being around him and his kid
because I'm like no but he's you know parents know
what they're doing and [__] he's such a great
dad so yes we will be continuing fatherhood uh thg
universe is Kevin have you had time to watch retro
freaks yet Dave Ryan and this just came out of the
sequels budget retro freaks is a movie that played
very well mind you at smodcast Castle Cinemas uh
and he gave me a copy to watch uh the truth is
no I have not I've been dealing with some [__]
um including my mom is in the hospital I was in
Florida all last week uh she's actually moved
a step closer toward Improvement and stuff she
they've been keeping her like [__] sedated like
[__] she intubated with the tube down her throat
and she's got another tube up her nose pumping
out her stomach and [__] like that long story
short don't get old kids I know the alternative
sucks but my God it's 77 is heartbreaking
but look we're not here to talk about that
and break hearts and [__] uh oh my God you're
right this is going to destroy the show Patrick
quill for five bucks says love your movies Kevin
thank you for making them I love you Patrick well
um big fan of your [__] cousin's
work I'm sorry I'm going to
it's destroying the show already isn't it yeah
um have them bid up for the Q a spot that's what
you do tell them [__] dope man that's a good
idea tell them I just did I know but put it into
better words than just you should sell them your
super chats for the end of the show during the Q a
session there's a guy there's a guy who's thinking
and that's a producer [__] YouTube well [__]
will does a show on YouTube called nut heads and
he's done it for a thousand years so will is also
a YouTuber who understands a thing or two about
a thing or two thank God he's here this week and
not Banff man because Batman would be too busy
[__] blowing Star Wars and [__] like that at
least [__] dilf man could say something smart
like that however from blacks the poodle gave
us Bruno bullax the poodle gave us 37 bucks just
to say in a row that's class right there come on
man that's awesome um okay uh sad boy gave us
[__] 4.99 Savoy 1984 pound sterling I don't
know why I get excited for money from one he
said thanks for making Mall Rats was that the
was the first that made me feel like I belonged
oh my God you're gonna make me [__] cry man
like that's legit that's a legit compliment
um all right no more Super Chat man we gotta
concentrate on the [__] show like [__]
dilfman said before he disappeared and [__]
um save up your [__] Super Chat money for when
we get to the question and answer part then you
can [__] like then we might do more than three
[__] questions if everyone's paying for this
[__] and you can buy our favor this is the
episode where we jumped the sharks at me however
me and Mark are gonna make an extra 100 to [__]
jump that shark man it's gonna be worth it we
don't give a [__] my favorite part of the show
had always been Kevin reads the chat a lot [Music]
it's true I have to [__] stop oh my god dude
King Ethan just paid us 49.99 he said Kevin and
Mark no question just wanted to say thank you for
the content he flew from Florida to LA to visit
JC's bar in September of 2022. he had a blast he
drank two wakanda Forevers safe travels to JC from
London love you guys King Ethan the [__] man
like my liege uh thank you so much have a [__]
sweet um kids stop stop paying money though I
feel [__] guilty this sounded like a cute idea
but now I'm like real [__] money man you could
just do a stream where you say it's q a guys for
an hour she's gonna be me ask me what you want
super [__] Chatters get to the top of the list
otherwise I'm here for an hour you don't even
have to do a real [__] show did you just hear
my [__] brain snap as I realized that you're
absolutely right oh my God [__] my life has
changed today as a [__] Super Chat I am all I
know I don't know how to make movies you ask any
critic they'll [__] tell you all I know how to
do is is [__] answer questions that's all I've
been doing for the last nearly 30 years I've
trained for this moment man the moment where
somebody's like I'll give you fifty dollars to ask
you a question like oh my God I'm ready for that
uh but we gotta do a show so let's jump into the
show we gotta do a show there's some [__] that
had dropped in the internet there's some [__]
that we've both seen in the world I figured we'll
cover that or read an ad and then we'll get into
some Star Wars goodness shall we do the ad first
I don't know will is it too early for the ad
or no dilf man tell us tell us what to do we've
had an hour of questions from Super Chat I think
we're good this is definitely what we would call
mid-roll so we're mid we can't escape it we're mid
[__] I wanted to be what's the opposite of mid
uh uh did his middle mid is Middle yeah a
lot of people are like just showing even
that anymore now you just [__] answered super
chat questions we'll be Apex yeah we're Apex well
you know we ain't no Predators I was about to say
Predators but [__] that's a horrible thing to
say uh kids this show wouldn't be happening
we're not for our sponsors although now
the game has changed man sponsors we could have
super Chatters paying for this whole [__] Affair
uh but but one of the [__] sponsors who have
stayed with this show through thick and thin
ladies and gentlemen uh are the good folks are
good friends at native uh you know we love native
and stuff uh while we're talking about them uh
give your skin the protection it deserves with
natives mineral sunscreens go to nativedeo.com
Fatman right now or use the promo code Fatman
at checkout to get 20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo code Fatman
at checkout nativedeo.com famine or use the promo
code Fatman I always begin the commercial with
the end of the commercial so that people could
follow along by going to that website and ship
but let's talk about [__] native I literally
put some native deodorant on today before I went
to [__] do the Jane Silent Bob shoot bam I use
the products that we talk about for heaven's sakes
and I know Mark does as well absolutely I love
anything that makes me smell like something you
want to eat man and Native does this [__] all
the time you can smell like sugar cookies you can
smell it candy canes you can smell like [__]
flat out candy that's what they did last month
but today we're talking about this I love the
feeling of soaking up the sun this time of year
do I I mean I hike running all the time so [__]
like I don't I guess I never thought about it but
I do look you look healthy you look like you've
been outside in the sun well number one I have
but number two this may be makeup I I don't know
no no you got a nice uh you got a nice glow to
you well I was in Florida and I was [__] going
I did the three mile walk around this lake with
my brother every day that I was there and then
since I got back I've been hiking running as
per usual running Canyon is like literally right
outside my house and stuff so it's a Four Mile
Walk door to door and historically Mark I've never
[__] used uh sunscreen I will now though native
sunscreen with all that time in the sun I'm
always worried about protecting my skin Kevin
Smith said from his own imagination not from
copy uh but with Native sunscreen I could give
my skin the protection it needs and soak up
some much needed Sun natives quickly absorbing
ultra sheer hydrating and lightweight sunscreen
formula offers broad spectrum SPF 30 protection
from UVA UVA and UVB rays man I actually should
start using this [__] to be honest with you
because I more than I ever do go ahead as one
of our Caucasian Americans you absolutely should
thank you but as one of these Caucasian Americans
I've always tried to be up like white Irish pale
so you know it'd be nice to have any sort of
complexion other than translucent whatnot so when
I go out I never think about putting on sunscreen
but I will now because I trust the [__] good
Folks at Native man they have not done me wrong
with [__] body wash [__] shampoo with [__]
deodorant and [__] like that native is amazing
so that being said man all Native sunscreen is
made of a 20 active zinc oxide formula that is
dermatologist tested and suitable for sensitive
skin like supposedly mine is all Native sunscreen
is made with oils derived from Plants said this
vegan uh that's seal and don't get on my
[__] about being vegan I almost died of
a heart attack five years ago you probably didn't
hear about it because I never [__] talk about it
um plants that's that seal in skin moisture
and is vegan and cruelty free cruelty free we
like as well we love animals we're
not animal haters here and [__]
one of us is an animal eater but [__] you know
because I don't like them they just happen to be
delicious exactly he loves an animal but he just
he loves it a little too much if they can taste
worse then I'd be down to not eat them thank you
uh choose from one of native's three delicious but
subtle scents like coconut and pineapple Rose or
Sweet Peach and nectar for your face or body or
try native's unscented option [__] that I'd
be putting pineapple all over my face coconut
pineapple those are two things that come from the
earth that I can [__] get behind man it actually
put in my goddamn mouth because I'm a vegan but
I hate [__] things that grow out of the Earth
um they I said please mention your favorite scent
mine is [__] pineapple and coconut right there
with all Native sunscreen you get protection
from the Sun that is free of chemical actives uh
oxybenzone and oxygen OCTA octanoxate that sounds
like a villain [__] Marvel comic um I can't
believe I said Marvel really I know well sometimes
I deal with [__] that don't come from our world
and [__] you got to be like a Marvel comic
book and like oh I've heard of Marvel and [__]
um Apple benzone [__] all that which makes
native sunscreen compliant with the Hawaii act
104 which was passed in an effort to protect
Hawaii's reefs come on man native's doing the
Lord's work over here man call the action kids
give your skin the protection it deserves of
natives mineral sunscreens go to nativedeo.com
Fatman or use the promo code Fatman at checkout
to get 20 off your first order man that that's
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo code Fatman
at checkout nativedeo.com Fatman say it with
me kids nativedeo.com Fatman winky dinky dog or
use the promo code fat man kids we thank the good
Folks at Native for sponsoring this show although
[__] now that Super Chat lives and there's a 99
Super Chat Jesus a hundred dollars somebody asked
to [__] ask a question with olive oil voices and
proper pole dancing charm you too Can Make It Rain
Paper Chasing in Hollywood without even having to
work the boulevards that's from Joshua mundle Josh
stop paying [__] legitimate American dollars
to [__] say [__] you could just say [__]
and I'll [__] read it man that's nuts that's
a lot of money 100 bucks man Josh must be [__]
rich I don't know why I'm [__] asking Studios
for money I'm gonna ask Munhall for some of that
[__] sweet Mund Hall money and [__] Super
Chat me something man how much people keep pay me
to keep Super Chat on because I found out I have
access to the on and off button other than that
you could kill it or or more to the point I can
enable it when we really need it during the show
what a good point man uh Hey man CA 69 99 that
means Canadian right yeah Daryl Benz from Canada
one of my favorite [__] countries on the planet
says thoughts on Picard season three and thanks
for what you guys do you guys make me laugh you're
the card guy give it to him I am and that was
actually one of the things I wanted to talk about
so thank you for offering us a lovely segue into
the podcast we were supposed to be doing I would
say it like that [__] people are paying real
money man why don't you hold that thought though
because instead of people subscribing to Super
Chat Kevin maybe you could tell them other ways
they could spend time with you for their money at
small Castle Cinemas or this weekend at Flappers
in Burbank Jeff's kiss [__] you are a producer
dilf man Banff man is just [__] all over
Star Wars [__] Johnson and [__] stealth Man
actually coming in producing we got to have them
both on the show Banff man and then dilfman can
come in to actually [__] make sure that we're
doing [__] we should be doing kids do you want
to [__] see me in the real world uh if you're
in Los Angeles I spend a lot of time in Jersey
now so a lot of people see me at smog Castle we'll
talk about that in a minute but you know for years
I've been out here 21 22 years I've been living
out in Hollywood and [__] and you know we used
to do live podcast [__] Galore we used to do
Hollywood Babylon every goddamn week Jane Sal
and Bob get old every [__] week uh but now it's
a rare Bird a rare bird that's a look like a bird
yeah sure maybe it should be this better thank
you it was a funny tree yes it's a rare tree a
rare Venus flytrap uh when I get to do a show
here in Los Angeles but don't you [__] touch
that dial because this Saturday at Flappers Comedy
Club me and Ralph Garman gonna be doing Hollywood
Babylon the show we've been doing for 12 almost
13 years at this point kids uh we had a great
old time the last show we did we were supposed to
do a show in March uh but then I had a thing and
I couldn't get back to Los Angeles so we moved
the show to April 15th so that's this Saturday
man at Flappers Comedy Club come see me and Ralph
doing Hollywood Babylon Ralph Garman one of the
funniest [__] people I know um and I sit next to
him and laugh the whole [__] time and stuff uh
this will only be the second Hollywood Babylon
I've ever done without being [__] completely
baked out of my mind as of tomorrow mark it'll
Mark 11 weeks Weed Free oh that's that's almost
what two and a half months something like
that who needs math when you got super chat
and [__] like that who needs weed when you got
super chat I might not have been stoned for the
last 15 years had I known about [__] Super Chat
because that's worth [__] dancing for man never
mind I appreciate how Alex deardoff spent 1.99
in Super Chat to say please turn Super Chat off
Alex you're gonna have to pay a lot more
than 1.99 to get turned this [__] off oh
my God Sixto Reynoso hit the hundred dollar Mark
just to say please call out two friends and the
movies with two friends in the movies with
Matt and Sixto where all podcasts are found
accepts podcasts proud sponsor of fat man
beyond accepts podcast um proud sponsor of
fat man beyond so there it is kids two friends
and the movies with Matt and Sixto 100 [__]
dollars did you know that you could buy Silent
Bob this cheaply that's they shouldn't be able to
yeah I'm happy to advertise their show are
you kidding me this is [__] this super
chat's gonna change my life this will be the
moment where everybody's like you know where
he went off the deep end where he realized
he could [__] beg for money on YouTube my
favorite part is half of the chat coming in now
just saying what fresh hell have I stepped into
um yes I'm coming I saw it coming 45 minutes
ago this is the beginning of the end my friend
if this is the end then I'm happy to [__]
end it this way getting 100 from 60 right no
so to say two friends in the movies with Matt
and six though man that's [__] that's genius
um kids I know you're asking yourselves well wait
Hollywood Babylon is happening at Flappers comedy
club uh this Saturday tickets at ceasemod.com come
join us and [__] uh when can I see you and Mark
doing fat man beyond well we uh are gonna be doing
fat man Beyond in Los Angeles of course at scum
and villainy uh as soon as JC gets back and we
figure out our dates but I'm gonna give you a long
[__] term date wave down the [__] Pike as they
say when me and Mark are returning to smog Castle
to do the next fat man beyond from smog Castle
which is when Mark I believe it is August 25th
if I remember I think you're right I'm gonna look
at my schedule right here this modcastle keeper
Ernie O'Donnell is chime in and tell me not to
talk about some other [__] uh August 25th 7 P.M
fat man return Batman Beyond returns to smodcast
castle at uh smart Castle Cinemas in Atlantic
Highlands New Jersey and [__] for the second
episode that we'll ever record live there we had
a [__] blast it was one of my favorite shows we
ever [__] did doing it was fun castle so now the
bar is set very [__] high I believe tickets are
on sale right now at smodcastlecinemas.com if you
want to get a jump on everybody else and we may
or may not be doing we talked about in the last
episode that we did we were joking around it
was a [__] punter where it happened during
The Ides of March during one of the screenings
yeah we were talking about um Legend I think for
like half an hour and the Majesty of Tim Curry and
then then I pitched you because apparently the way
to get yourself a screening series at smart Castle
Cinemas is to have the good pun so the Ides of
Mark was a good enough pun um to get three days to
do that and then I pitched keep calm and Curry on
keep keep calm and carry on is a proposed
uh um Tim Curry appreciation Festival yeah
double feature I think which we're not allowed to
talk about because Ernie said hey man don't talk
about that yet because first we have to score the
movie with the actual uh exhibit or Distributors
and stuff so but if you're gonna come see us
on August 25th for fat man beyond leave August
26 open not saying why but could be that that's
where we're all going to keep calm and and Curry
on man [__] smart Castle kids so much coming
to smodcast Castle um May I just give you I know
this show seems like one big commercial now but
can I tell you what's coming to smodcast Castle
I'm gonna be back there on four well number one
Mission Hill is coming to do a show on April
14th man like uh the the member of Mission Hill
the TV show finished some episodes and they tore
them around the country so they're coming this
modcastle to do that if you love Mission Hill come
see them do the live show uh They show cartoons
then they talk about it afterwards and stuff
um as for me and mine 420 the high holiday if you
will you want to spend it with a guy who doesn't
smoke weed come to my castle Cinemas we're going
to show Jane Sal and Bob reboot watch Jane Silent
Bob reboot with me and mubi the golden calf
we're taking pictures and [__] like that as
well that's on 420. on 421 which is a Friday we're
doing this thing I'm very excited about uh called
Trailer Park which is uh come watch 90 minutes of
trailers from the 70s 80s and 90s with with me we
just sit there and watch movie trailers oftentimes
the best part of any movie going experience I
believe we all agree these are classic trailers
from back in the day man uh Stephen are are a
digital guru at smog Castle uh it kind of stemmed
from when we did The Ides of Mark he was putting
up trailers for cool ass [__] old movies and
I was like we should do this for like 90 minutes
straight he's like we can so that's happening on
421 uh on 422 of course sold out you can't get
tickets we're doing Chasing Amy with Jason Lee
going to be back in town but like I said that's
all sold out but get this [__] man on May 5th
on May 5th May the 4th of course is Star Wars
Day May 5th is Revenge of the of the fifth but
we're doing a show called revenge of the Smith
because my name is Smith and so basically you know
in all my movies I've always done [__] Star Wars
oriented material well we're gonna sit there I'm
going to show you every [__] Star Wars scene
from a movie I've ever made and then I'm gonna
pause it and [__] tell you the story of how it
happened and why it happened and [__] revenge of
the Smith is happening at smog Castle Cinemas on
May 5th and then on May 6 come watch Jane Silent
Bob Strike Back with me and Jason Muse Jason Muse
coming to Smart Castle man to show [__] uh
Jane sound Bob Strike Back Then on May 7th
we're going to show drawn flies which is a movie
my friend Malcolm Ingram made in 1995 this is kind
of spiritual sequel at Mall Rats because a lot of
our casts they went up to Vancouver and shot this
movie about looking for bigfoot uh Jason Lee gives
an amazing performance of this movie that was so
good it made me rewrite the part of Banky and
Chasing Amy because I was like this guy could do
a lot more than [__] what I give him credit for
doing Brody and [__] like that Jason Muse is in
that Renee Humphries is in it I pop up in it and
stuff Scott moser's in it wearing a [__] diaper
Ethan Supply pops up and I'm telling you it's
like Mallrats too for [__] sake um is it black
and white Canadian classic ladies and gentlemen
that's happening on May 5th 7th director Malcolm
Ingram gonna be in the house JMU is going to be
in the house I will of course always be in the
house tickets at smodcastcastlecinemas.com and
the last thing I'll promote for the time being
but please go to smartcastlecinemas.com website
and see all the [__] we got coming including on
[__] well I'll tell you about this first we're
doing a uh the Jersey Girl the Snyder cut ladies
and gentlemen which on the internet has become
shorthand for an uncut version of the movie the
longest version of Jersey girl that you never saw
including so much JLo that you could shake a stick
at all the J-Lo that got cut out of the movie
during its theatrical run is going to be playing
during the Jersey Girl the Snyder cut that is on
uh May 28th um but but you know flash is coming
The Flash uh of course June 16th so the weekend
of June 16th June 17 June 18th I'm going to be at
every nighttime showing of The Flash just watch
The Flash with me man and hopefully we're gonna
show Batman Returns that week we'll see if Warner
Brothers lets us um I can't wait but I'm going to
see flash early man because uh was April 24th 25th
26th 27th is Cinema con used to be called show
west now it's Cinema con which is like Comic-Con
for people that own movie theaters and [__]
um exhibitors if you will and they're showing
[__] The Flash like two months before it
comes out and [__] and I don't know if they're
gonna make me sign an NDA but like I'm watching
the [__] out of them so I'll be back to be like
it is everything that Tom Cruise says what did you
see that news story where like Tom Cruise saw
the Flash and he was like it's great I love it
I love it um so I can't wait to go to cinemacon
see the [__] flesh that's why I bought a badge
just to go see the [__] Flash and stuff and
there's other movies they're debuting and stuff
but I'm there to see the [__] that's the flash
any event bunch of [__] happen if you want to
see me on the west coast Hollywood Babble on this
weekend this Saturday if you want to see me on the
East Coast tons of [__] shows at smodcast Castle
Cinemas go to smartcastlecinemas.com or csmod.com
for tickets thank you for pointing all that out
uh dilf man our producer I I like literally would
have forgotten because I'm so enamored of Super
Chat cannot believe that people are given money
just to say a thing how lovely um but however
and Kevin their comments will be there later
you can click the little dollar sign at the top
of the chat we can come back to them later they
don't worry about it just is that right
yes this [__] knows everything give it
up for [__] dilf man it keeps popping off the
screen and [__] but he used to be down there
um all right enough about all that shall we
dive into the meat of the show let's do it
let's let's do a quick uh round robin of the ship
that you and I have seen either together or apart
um you've talked about Mandalorian the most
recent episode of it the one with Jack Black
and lizzo as space paramours that seems like the
episode that everyone online is like that's where
jump the [__] shark that's their Super Chat
episode I guess a lot of people unhappy with
the appearance of Jack Black and lizzo a lot of
people specifically mad that lizzo knighted grogu
in one of the moments you know I I didn't bump
into that I was like whatever if that's what you
want to do with guest stars and [__] like that
that's totally cool I mean Christopher Lloyd was
on the [__] show all right Chris for Lloyd but
who don't love Jack Black especially this week
[__] Super Mario Brothers like made every dollar
in the world and he's got that peaches video like
on [__] YouTube and [__] like that yeah
that's blown up but he's eligible for an Oscar
is it really written for the movie um but yet
my man all he does is shows up on Mandalorian
and everybody's like uh I I didn't bump into it
at all I don't give a [__] like having a Star
Wars TV show you'll never hear a complaint out
of me and [__] especially now that we've heard
from but Dave filoni it's celebration they're
gonna wrap all that shut up in a [__] movie
yeah don't don't jump the news don't worry about
that later flew over to you what did you think
um I I am mystified by this season of the
Mandalorian um because it I don't I don't
really know what story it's telling anymore
other than maybe we're going to retake Mandalore
eventually kind of but then again benjarin doesn't
really give a [__] about that part of the lore
like he just kind of wants to hang out with
grogu as does I feel like most of the world
um and so every episode does not seem to
be about him or nor does it seem to be
about grogu now we're in the Boca tan show
which I love Katie Sackhoff she's wonderful
um I like the character of Boca tan I'm not as
uh welded to her as some people are because I
wasn't a Clone Wars kid so all of this sort
of Mandalore lore is a little bit like okay
it's a flavor I guess but suddenly it's
become the entire meal that we're eating
um and yes the Mandalorian can refer to
lots of different people apparently but
that's what I read in a story this week online
like uh because it said like you know Pedro Pascal
is no longer the [__] Mandalorian and I thought
it was a story about how somebody else plays him
and he just does the voice but it's literally
like somebody with the show not [__] favro
or felony or whatever Summit I think the guy one
of the directors Rick for me maybe I'm not sure
but somebody [__] said that hey man what does
the Mandalorian mean it don't have to mean him
could be bo Katan could be [__] groguing [__]
they've what we all thought the Mandalorian title
referred to to Jin Jin Jaren Mando can now be
broader about something else or whatever I don't
know I passed a billboard every [__] day here
in town where it's clearly [__] didn't it's
clearly the Mandalorian [__] flying around GoGo
in his arms so I you know even though some of the
stories this year have deviated like that one
would Dr Pershing and stuff which had almost
no Mando just in the beginning and just at the
tail end um I don't bump into that I'm like look
man I don't mind they go on Flights of Fancy and
stuff uh however we only have one or two episodes
left for this season I think it's only eight eight
episodes this season yeah you know and so to spend
again I just don't know the story they're telling
because they all right we're going to spend an
episode rescuing this [__] kidnapped Mandalorian
kid from weird space vultures okay sure I guess we
can do that I don't know what that has to do
with the the main story but maybe there is no
main story maybe we're just going back to episode
of the week it's just gonna be this and now it's
going to be like you know Law and Order Coruscant
or whatever where we've got to find you know it's
not Coruscant I know but we've got to find out
like who's poisoning the droids and making them
angry and then we're just it's a detective show
it's you know it's [__] Matlock with a couple
of mandalorians and masks asking to walk in space
Matlock in space and it's like but I don't because
I don't know what then John wants anymore and
because I don't really know what grogu wants
anymore I don't know how any of these episodes are
continuing that story I know what Boca 10 wants
very much um and so maybe it is just becoming
her show and the same with the book of Boba
Fett became Mandalorian show became denjarin
Show excellent point that's true we thought we
were watching the Boba Fett show and then suddenly
it was the Mandalorian and Ahsoka show yeah yeah
um Stanley and chat who paid nothing to say this
this made me smile made me laugh he goes please
hate on Star Wars and Marvel they deserve it no
they didn't they don't no they don't remember when
there was a world where this [__] didn't exist
and we all dreamed of like why don't they do this
[__] as a TV show now they are I can't hate on
it man um even if even if like [__] Jack Black's
got a bushy beard and playing a big character I
I was happy for him I was like look he's in Star
Wars too uh like I did the Jack Black lizzo thing
didn't bother me you know just because the entire
episode was bothersome to me they didn't stand
out as like oh it's their fault like no it's
actually I don't know what we're doing anymore
you know like dinjarin makes this big thing where
he explains how it's like well she uh I lost the
dark saber because this creature attacked me and
then she killed a creature so by right she belongs
she should have the dark saber cool you could have
told her that at any moment over the last four
episodes but you didn't until it was dramatic
like really okay she could have just had it and
you can't even use it you were just being a queen
about it yes Queen uh Stanley didn't pay anything
for super chat but he's getting his money because
Mark is hating on Star Wars for you everybody uh
Jazz PDX who also did not [__] pay anything to
ask this question said are Fabs and felony getting
creative interference or is it all them I saw an
article where John Favreau was like nobody's
telling me what to do this is just what I want
to do I I didn't read like creative interference
to me it doesn't read like [__] Disney being
like you should do this or you should do this I
think a guy's got his own [__] TV show you can
do anything he wants with it and [__] and I'm
sure he meets famous people all the time who are
like oh I love that [__] show and you know he's
started popping them in to the show like I I don't
know it didn't read like this is all [__] Disney
doing it Disney's ruining Star Wars I I think
they could use some creative interference like I I
think that that the show is suffering a little bit
because there's nobody but these two guys making
Star Wars and when it works it's great but like
there's a reason why we do have writer rooms
there's a reason why that collective experience
is a net good thing in television I mean if Tony
Gilroy can have a writer's room for Andor then
there's no reason why and invite other people in
and collaborate and together make a great thing
I think I think Mando is suffering
a little bit from some tunnel vision
um but hey that's just me on the outside looking
in um and and yes we are we are probably coming to
the end of the Mando cycle as you intimated
um but I just I remember when it was a show
about a bounty hunter who found a kid and
there were no Jedis and there was no lore
and it was just a thing that everybody could
kind of jump onto and then by now the Midway
through the third season it has become this
somewhat Byzantine exploration of the nooks
and crannies of the Star Wars universe that if
you haven't done the reading is a little bit
I don't know opaque uh look oh my God [__] I was
just gonna give you props for Byzantine which I
always say Byzantine like [__] you then you then
[__] close you stick The Landing with opaque
words oh my God Mark it's the [__] vocabulary of
the day award for both nobody gonna say anything
is smart in this show as Mark just expressed
it whether you agree with the sentiment or not
Byzantine and [__] opaque are just like billion
dollar words to just casually drop in conversation
man take that if you're gonna take anything from
the show number one take that we jump the shark
with Super Chat take that take Byzantine [__]
opaque into your daily conversations kids that's
what you get when you watch a fat man beyond
show you get the smarts you get the smarts
um Picard season three is phenomenal the card
season three is I think everything that everybody
who was ever a fan of the Next Generation always
wanted Picard to be and I say that as a person who
worked on season two um I think that that you know
this is this is the version of the show that that
uh the shareholder Terry always wanted to do that
every writer has always wanted that every actor
who's ever been on on Next Generation wanted to
come back and play it this is the way to close out
storyline um it's it's just it's it's
great it is kind of unreservedly great
um except for one reservation which is the
jack Crusher stuff I could kind of give or take
um but is this the last season yes the final
season so do you think so then is that why it's
great and everything that everyone ever wanted
it to be because they're like well this is it
the last hurray it does have the feeling of like
just you know there's no reason to leave anything
behind there's no reason to leave any ammunition
in the in the in the in the guns just blow all
the barrels like do all the things leave it all in
the field and and it is it is Nostalgia for sure
um but it's nostalgic it gets to be surprising
in ways as Nostalgia that gets to be
um warming in ways and emotional in ways but
it's also proper Star Trek there's also like
[__] phaser battles and and spaceship combat
and Amanda Plummer as this wonderful villain
um it's just anybody honey bunny is continuing her
villainous ways and taking them to outer space in
the game um but yeah man I I completely take it
I completely dig it um let's see John Wick four
which both of us have seen um independent of one
another John Wick 4 is essentially four or five
of the most incredible 25 minute action
sequences anyone has ever tried to commit to film
um we did I watched it at smog Castle Cinemas
and we did a watch Wick with Kev so I was just
in town and it was a Saturday night I was
going to watch John Wick so I was like come
watch it with me we'll do q a afterwards and
stuff I'll do q a for a movie I had nothing
to do with and my God like at first when I
sat down in my seat like her smodcast to keep
Ernie O'Donnell is like I hope you got two
hours and 40 minutes and I was like wise
like that's how long this movie is I was like
what like you're talking about [__] who made
clerks three it was like 94 minutes and [__]
I cut my [__] to the Bone and whatnot and I
was like I ain't got time for [__] two hours
and 30 40 minutes whatever the [__] it was
[__] went by like that [__] [__] flew
by even at that length man it was incredible
um I you know I we had a discussion afterwards
about like is what's the influence here is it
[__] one long cartoon or is it video games
or what the [__] and I was like what it is
is you could do some [__] with special effects
now that you never could before somebody said
like it's a mixture of [__] um you know the Shaw
Brothers and and and Looney Tunes to some degree
um all it was was [__] magic I read a story
where Keanu went through and [__] crossed
out a lot of the dialogue so it only has about
300 words that he says in the whole movie but
there's a guy who knows his character knows what
the audience wants and [__] it was not wanting
for [__] dialogue breathless in terms of like
the action sequences there's one like Touch of
Evil shot in that [__] just went on and on and
on like the overhead shot dragon's breath shotgun
just sparking [__] into fire and [__] like
this I'm sorry but the the [__] Sacred Heart
sequence the stairs sequence was just [__]
brilliant man because when he gets to the spoilers
kids it's been out for a red hot minute but this
don't spoil the movie if you ain't seen it it
should make you want to see it [__] there's this
uh uh the church in in France that ain't the one
that went on fire it's not Notre Dame but it's the
other one and it's all they're big [__] selling
point it's like these stairs will give you a
[__] heart attack because there's so many stairs
to get up to the church and [__] they do an
entire action sequence on these [__] stairs and
just when [__] Wick makes it to the top of the
[__] stairs somebody kicks them all the way down
the stairs he has to do it again it was [__]
brilliant that moment alone I was like because I
was like yeah he's at the top of the stairs let's
go and they're like oh no they really know what
they're doing with this [__] series man it's
absolutely [__] phenomenal uh and the audience
that I was with ate it up like candy wasn't a
single person at the end of it you know I go like
how many people liked it all the hands went up I
was like how many people didn't like it no [__]
hands went up um it's just astounding to watch and
it's weird that like I can't even consider myself
as a filmmaker when I watch a film like this
because I'm like holy [__] now you know I
understand that a lot of digital help and [__]
like is [__] directed by a guy a stunt man right
the guy yeah oh my God this guy's [__] so
talented this kid give him all the money and
make every [__] move give him every one of the
franchises give him a Star Wars give him a Marvel
let this guy do whatever he [__] wants because
my God this movie was vastly entertaining here's
the highest compliment I could pay it as I sat
there watching it I wished my [__] father who's
been dead for 20 years in June could be exhumed
from the [__] ground with a Necronomicon just so
I can show him this movie my father was an action
movie [__] freak if he'd seen this [__] movie
he might be alive today this movie would have kept
him alive if he knew this movie was coming one day
it is it's it's just so [__] good did you like
it um I think every one of those action scenes is
maybe the best action scene I've ever seen right
like [__] hands down bro I was thinking like
how many other movies in action over the years and
[__] but I'm like oh my God this is breathtaking
yeah but I will also say you could probably
cut half of those action scenes and I would
have enjoyed the movie just as much fair enough
it did not have to be as long as it was and like
there's there's very little suspense or pluck or
character being conveyed in any of those scenes
right like it's here I am in this hotel in Japan
which is super cool and it's filled with [__]
assassins and I'm gonna kill them all and make
my way out right right do we learn anything new
about John Wick no you learn anything new about
the plot no it's just can he make it out alive
and of course you can because he's John Wick
and so it becomes it becomes a little numbing
after a while when you're just like all right
so we did a cool overhead action scene and then
we're in the The Arc of Triumph car chase scene
where people jumping out and get killed and it's
amazing and then we're doing a staircase scene
and that's 40 minutes of just things exploding
and cars screeching and guns firing which is a
lot if there's no emotional tether to any of it
you know is there did you not have an emotional
tender this is a this is a this all began mind
you with a guy really upset that they killed a
[__] puppy and I love the first movie The First
movie is perfect but it doesn't have it doesn't
have what this movie had like it feels like
they started in a very realistic kind of world
with the first one and I've not watched The Fast
and Furious movies but like you have oh yes your
description of them was like because I remember
the first one and I was like it's just about car
racing and you're like oh it's gone beyond that
bro they go to space yeah and it feels like
they've upped the ante every [__] go around
um but I I'm here for it man like I loved what
they did in [__] chapter four John Wick chapter
four yeah but remember the very simple premise
of John Wick like this is a man who's pissed off
that they killed this [__] dog and his wife but
dog first and [__] yeah but it was it was the
like my wife died and the last gift she gave to
me was this dog to help me grieve so I wouldn't
have to grieve her death alone and you killed
that symbol of of Salvation that I had so I'm
going to lay ways to everybody to get my [__]
revenge and he does okay I get it that's pure
it's simple by this movie it seems as if it's
going to be about John Wick the only way he
can get out and live a life is to get rid of
the high table completely right I gotta kill
of last [__] dude to kill and you're like
oh all right cool it's gonna be this Marquee
guy right who's super fun like yeah all
of his suits are amazing the amount of
like just Venom that oozes from from that
dude one of the Skarsgard Stars guard boys
he's great but then somebody says oh well if you
just kill him they'll replace him with somebody
else but let's all do this says Winston The
Amazing Ian McShane so I can get my hotel back
and so John Wick dies asterisk so that
another dude can get his hotel back
he doesn't get rid of the high table he doesn't
get revenge for his wife like all of it is kind
of just like a real estate transaction and at the
end of all that I kind of wanted it to mean more
and it really doesn't you know it's just it's a
little bit futile and if that's the point they
wanted to make okay that's a choice that like
all of that death ultimately doesn't amount
to anything that there is no there is no getting
rid of this system the best you can do is try to
live your life in a way that you can find some
honor in I get it but it's also a little like
for this movie in which this dude is a superhero
like it's going to be an oddly Hollow ending and
the asterisk is because I don't think John Wick
is dead if they decide they want to make another
movie I think I think the director was it's Chad
chance to housekeep yeah Chad stachelski has said
there's going to be a chapter five yeah I mean
they're like maybe a spin-off about the Donnie
Yen character who's super cool Kane he's great you
know they're definitely doing a ballerina movie
out of the whole like Russian ballerina assassin
training school um and you know they're like well
we'll see if we have another idea but if you don't
see a body going into a coffin and a coffin going
into a grave then it's not a character who has to
be dead and we saw the same [__] gravesite for
for Nick Fury like eight times and that [__]
never seems to die so he's got I saw him in a
trailer for a [__] secret Invasion he's back
like crazy yeah yeah so like I I appreciate these
movies with what for what they do to the craft
and and Chad is a he's he's a wizard at this and
he's figured out a way to advance the technology
of stunts and of action and a lot of that stuff
is practical I mean there's some CG stuff for sure
but like keanu's doing like 90 of that stuff yes I
mean it's [__] at one point dude he's working
nunchucks where you're like how's this guy have
time to be a nunchucks expert like he's in [__]
so many movies and [__] and he's older than me
and you right he's got like 55 56 years old yeah
he's almost [__] working the Chucks like [__]
nobody's business it was so awesome that when
he stopped working the Chucks he just let him
hang around his neck and then [__] picked him
back up and [__] one we had a good time after
the movie during the Q a talking about I had um
Shane uh who's my A.D on clerks three Shane Kalman
um was there watching with me so I was like you
get up and do q a with me and [__] because I was
like Shane how long does it take to do something
like the art the Triumph scene and [__] and we
were trying to break down for the audience how
much of it was real and how much of it was [__]
done elsewhere and stuff you know because we had
definitely had some people in the audience who
thought like all that traffic was really there and
I'm like oh no so much of that comes together in
post and whatnot but do you think he was actually
working nunchucks or do you think he's doing this
[__] and they put nunchucks in his hand later
on I think he's working them I mean that's what
I thought I was like meaning that he does I mean
Chad Chad did a lot of press I mean there's been
a ton of pressure on each one of these movies
but he said like I bring the stunt team in
you know four to six months before we start
shooting and Keanu is training for six to
eight months before we start shooting so
that he can do as much of it as possible
and like all of the martial arts stuff
and stuff he's doing like he's not
there's there's always the line between like are
we gonna kill Keanu or are we just going to ding
Keanu and it's like he's taking a lot of those
hits we're not slamming him into Vans at 100
miles an hour like that's either a stunt guy or CG
but like Keanu wants to do it all Keanu like every
time the gun jams that they use it's because the
gun really jammed and Keanu just knows what to do
and he knows how to play it as part of a scene
he knows what John Wick would do with Jan Dunn
and I also Mike to your point we talked about
this years ago years ago months ago I don't
know time there are no live rounds on the sets
of those movies it's like every gun is a non-fire
of a Gun there's no muzzle flash on the set like
everything is digital all of it it's like I just
won't there's no reason to do it as and we have
not done it on any of these movies like we can
we can fake the the slide going back and forth
we can eject empty shells onto the ground if
we have to but you could not put a bullet in any
gun that's on any one of these sets and fire it
which you have to give credit to the performers
because they make it look like just enough recoil
and [__] like that like he's not just going
like this and His Hands not really moving it looks
like they're firing [__] guns and I don't mean
visually it looks like it with the puzzle flash
that they add later on and stuff but to be an
actor in the middle of a [__] scene where you're
beating up a hundred [__] people and you still
have an in a uncut [__] shot that goes on for
minutes and you still have the presence of mind to
still [__] jerk just enough to have you [__]
be like yeah he's firing a [__] gun right there
they don't even have to then we have to fake it
because they've built it with like Motors inside
of it that that shimmy it just enough so when you
press the trigger the motor starts spinning and
it gives you that feel so you can see like flesh
jiggle when the gun is moving yeah right yeah
yeah like and I think they had it God when do they
have four remember WETA had worked on something
like that like 10 or 15 years ago because they
also realized back then maybe we don't need
bullets anymore we don't need blanks anymore
um but no I I think that the discreetly like every
10 minutes of that movie is a masterpiece I just
think that when you put it all together to two
hours and 40 minutes worth of it it uh the the the
parts I think are a little bit more than the whole
but that is just me um Joshua mondal who was one
of our [__] super Chatters asked a free question
Kevin Mark Berserker keanu's comic have you read
any of it yet what do you think of an upcoming
upcoming animated series slash movie have you ever
read his comic I have not read his comic um I know
others are doing it they are doing a cartoon right
I think Netflix got the rights and I think they
have a whole like Suite of things they want to
do with it I think they want to do a live action
thing I don't think they want to do an animated
thing I think that you know the Keanu of it gets
you quite a bit of of avenues of exploitation for
that and it seems fun it seems fun it's a boom
comic and the guys of Boom are super smart can I
tell you an inside [__] baseball story that I
think has something to do with that shoot so uh
years ago I was working on a live-action Buckaroo
Banzai TV series at first we sold it to Apple MGM
owns it at first we I got involved with the
good Folks at MGM because like we hear you
love buckaroo banza I was like [__] yeah I love
Bakugan so we pitched it to Apple got bought like
in a heartbeat and [__] was it apple or Amazon
Amazon first I think I don't know one of them
either Apple bought it first then Amazon bought it
after or Amazon bought it first and apple bought
it after ironically enough it was the same guy
both companies who bought it his name was Morgan
he was to do the bought it so we were doing a live
action version of the show um and they the whoever
we wound up with ultimately I think it was Apple
remember who went first they both begin with a
um so whoever was whether it was Apple or whether
it was Amazon it'd be somebody in chat [__]
remembers um they those cats were like I don't
know maybe it's not a live action series maybe
it's an animated series and so I got some cool
ass designs from the folks of Powerhouse animation
um guys who I do uh and girls with uh uh Masters
of the Universe with for Netflix in any event
they designed this um someone says gravitated
said would someone please get Kevin hi why
like I was more obnoxious when I was
I I was way more last time yeah truly
um so uh cool ass designs very manga very anime
influence for Buckaroo Banzai animated series
and I I cannot tell you how this happened but
somebody was like you know who's interested in
playing Buckaroo Banzai in your animated series
Keanu Reeves I was like what the [__] so they
hooked up Zoom with with me and and Keanu and
I'd met him once before also on Zoom uh for the
Bill and Ted uh face the music like uh Premiere
or whatever they put together this like online
[__] panel and stuff during the days of covet
and you know I was like oh my God I had to tell
him like look [__] we don't get to Silent Bob we
don't get to Jay and Silent Bob without Bill and
Ted and we don't get to sound bar without Theodore
uh Ted Theodore Logan and chip um and he was like
whoa and so here we are [__] a year or two after
that and we're doing another Zoom but this time
it's not in front of the world and [__] it's
just literally me and [__] Keanu and he goes
so Buckaroo Bonsai and I was like yeah man and and
we talked for like half an hour and this is this
is a like it's it's never happened in a [__]
but this is it ties into that Berserker thing
by the end of the conversation he was like
let's do this man and I was like oh my God
this Show's actually gonna [__] happen and
then one week later he sent me a lovely email
where he was like I have to back out of the show
he's gone I hope we get to work together one day
polite as [__] he's a Canadian kid so he's just
absolutely [__] wonderful and [__] I think
it probably had to do with Berserker because I
think he's like oh if I'm gonna do a cartoon I'm
gonna do cartoon based on my comic book lovely
lovely [__] dude but for one brief Shining
Moment for about a week or two week period we
could have had Buckaroo Banzai played by Keanu
Reeves in an animated series oh that would have
been amazing um Peter Weller for the record if
anyone was like what about [__] Peter Weller
he would have played Hanoi Shan uh who is if
you know the Buckaroo Bonsai world and the
book written by Earl the great Earl McGraw
um that's his Lex Luthor um that doesn't really
get much play in the Buckaroo Banzai movie
um but him in the book him and Lizardo are like
this and [__] now I'm falling down the rabbit
hole and whatnot but there you go anyway yes
so uh John Wick 4 made all the money it's
you know if they want to make a fifth they can
they're spaying it out a dozen different ways
um including a continental Continental TV series
right which I worked on um that's right you
did I did um I'm pretty sure that if I remember
correctly the Continental is now three TV movies
and not a TV series um but it was all about
the uh the how Winston gets the hotel it was
a it would be young Winston like not Winston you
know young Sharon um there were a couple of other
characters from the WIC universe that we were sort
of beginning to bring in but uh and we'd always
had this idea of like young [__] John Wick um
or jordani whatever his Russian name is jovanovic
um but I don't think we ever landed on a really
interesting way to bring him in to have made it
worth it but like season two or three will totally
bring in young John Wick um but uh but yeah no and
you know I got to work a little bit with Chad
in like picking his brain about how that world
works and he's a very intense but very nice guy
but he's always on he's always kind of moving
um never got to be Buchanan who I think is
is both nice but a little bit of the opposite
you know like Chad was intense but uh but yeah
he was very he was very cool but in text while
we're talking about Wick we should give a
shout out pour one out for Lance Reddick
indeed indeed this is the just as the movie
opened uh the concierge himself um passed
away like rather suddenly and also very young I
think we talked did we talk about it on the yeah
in the last part yeah like that was the breaking
news that day was like you know that's right rmp
um two quick trailers to hit before
we dig into Star Wars celebration
stuff there was a new across the
spider verse trailer that dropped
man alive just give it all to me yeah for one
like they may they bring in the spot was very fun
um it looks like a you know they get a lot of
jokes out of that character and [__] um but
[__] who knew that uh [__] Spider-Man 2099 was
gonna like play such a massive massive [__] part
yeah and played by what's as [__] Oscar Isaac
Oscar Eisen great Oscar eyes Moon Knight himself
who's like gets to be two [__] Marvel characters
in this world three if you count [__] apocalypse
indeed so yeah cannot wait for that
that's I think June I said June yeah
I think it's June that looks amazing
uh and also the bringing in [__]
Peter Peter Parker comes back
with [__] spider baby I know
um so I guess [__] worked out with him and Mary
Jane that's like I love that movie so much across
the the original uh into the spider-verse yeah
um and that trailer just has the line where you
know his mother is is talking to him on the roof
and it's just like you know you were a little boy
and I just don't want you to forget the the boy
that that we helped raise the boy that we love
and I want you to protect him and make sure that
he's okay and just like all of the feelings are
all bubbling in my body and I don't know what to
do about it it's beautiful beautiful [__] yeah
um and then the Blue Beetle trailer dropped
our first wonderful I thought it was really
strong man I was I honestly like Ted court is my
Blue Beetle and I was never like uh I was out of
comics by the time I may came around I'm well
aware of the character and whatnot but you know
I grew up reading Justice League International
[__] all the Blue Beetle [__] Booster Gold
[__] by uh damatus and Giffin and stuff so Ted
cord is was and will always be my Blue Beetle
um that being said holy [__] man like they've
made a [__] really good looking movie I hope
that this isn't one of these Shazam Fury
the gods things where they're like well
the same part of the James Gunn plan I hope going
forward they keep this up well I hope the movie's
as good as the trailer did you like the trailer
I dug the trailer I mean I think it's [__] man
yeah I think the the cutest playing Jaime Reyes
is super Charming that's the kid from [__]
Cobra Kai right yeah yeah I don't know what his
last name God he was so uh he was the heart of
Cobra Kai man at least season one and season two
I remember when he [__] like spoilers when he
gets [__] knocked off the railing and [__]
I was like oh like I was very happy in season
two yeah so I'm I'm looking forward to it the the
one quibble that I have is that superhero origin
stories are at this point not entirely interesting
to me because most of them are the same
you know it's the I found a piece of tech that
will transform my life and help change everything
from this piece of [__] to what I wanted to be
or I got bitten or exposed or irradiated or or my
parents got killed or something bad happened to my
parents that motivates me to do whatever or I'm an
alien and look I just found out all of that stuff
like we've seen the five or six variations on the
theme and so I I keep longing for either some
new version of that or to just skip right over
like if I ever see pearls again in a Batman
movie [__] you like I know this origin
already everybody does I don't ever need to see
Peter Parker get bitten by a spider again we
know how that works yes Kalel came from Krypton
we get it don't ever show me that [__] again
sounds like guns not going to show you that in
the movie that he's now directing as well as
writing yeah like it seems Superman Legacy is
very much about like a Superman who's already
Superman who has questions about what that is
and I'm all for that I mean it's we've been
telling that origin now for almost 90 years
I think we get it um so so yeah like I'm I'm
here for Blue Beetle I'm very curious about what
it is and what it looks like and how it operates
um and the trailer looks good it's just that
little bit of like okay no if if this follows
the beats that I know then you know it'll be those
things in the periphery that get me excited unless
the central core of what it is but I reserve
judgment until I see the movie and I live in Hope
filth yes nerd large I'm complaining about movies
that I haven't even watched yet and just said I
live at hope I haven't seen it yet this is trailer
simmer did that person pay money to ask you that
question he did not native someone wants to know
if they can negotiate the rate down to Super Chat
no Kevin I just wanted to contribute that uh
actually the Blue Beetle movie was supposed to
be an HBO Max film until James Gunn saw it and he
said no no no we're going theatrical is that right
that's the rumor I heard I don't know I'd always
heard that it was supposed to be theatrical and
then there was a danger that it might go he
[__] says [__] and then it [__] off I
was in the middle of a conversation get back here
Dylan right here man stand by yourself he's here
um I hadn't heard that I I thought it was always
meant to be theatrical and maybe during the Zas
law there there was a danger that it might go the
way of well not Batgirl and be [__] canceled but
it might just go to HBO Max but that would be a
new one I hadn't heard that uh speaking of Super
Chat though rain serving paid 10 bucks to say this
hey Kev I want to thank you for sharing your heart
attack story on the podcast years ago without it
my dad wouldn't be here today so I'll always be in
your dead number one thank you number two you're
in the debt of the doctors who saved your Dad's
life um I'm glad I said a thing and you maybe
heard a thing and when the time was right said
a thing to your [__] dad and I'm glad your dad's
alive and stuff um but for years people ever since
our zag and [__] I've been talking about it I've
met heard from people online met him in the real
world people giving me credit for saving their
lives saving the life of a loved one because I
talked about this heart attack [__] um I I did
not I just passed on some good information [__]
I didn't know and so that's you know been my Mo
for the last few years is like oh [__] I didn't
know this [__] so when I started telling the
story about my heart attack it was really passed
out information like you know I always thought
[__] your arms got to go numb or Elizabeth
you got to do a red fox in order to know you're
having a heart attack but like being nauseous
having the sweats these are all [__] warning
signs as well so I thank you for that rain uh but
you saved your Dad's life and more importantly the
doctors saved your Dad's life but I'm so glad your
dad's around take them for when we we're just
talking about Mark not wanting to see another
superhero origin and stuff and we talked about my
parents are dead like you know that was me making
jokes about Comics but instantly with flash to my
head is my dad is dead and that should have been
my superhero origin story moment but it's not it's
coming up in June it'll be dead 20 [__] years
like I said before when I was talking about [__]
John Wick I think about him when I see these
[__] movies now because I'm like oh my God like
that's what he loved when I showed him Chasing Amy
for the first time he fell asleep because that
wasn't his [__] speed and [__] I didn't have
Clint Eastwood in it didn't have a [__] single
gun or anything like that but man oh man if he
had lived to see Wick [__] my old man would be
let me see he died at six seven so he'd be 87 now
um so I don't know if he would have made it
regardless of his poor health and whatnot but
I wish he had I guarantee you if I could [__]
sink John Wick 4 into the bowels of the earth it
would raise my father's corpse if he weren't you
know cremated because I got a piece of him and a
nurn right over there my mom put him into this urn
God bless her I remember when my father died she's
like I bought your father the most beautiful urn
and she showed it to me and it was like this this
bronze Affair of like waves and it had three
Dolphins cresting over it and she's like that's
meant to be you and your brother and your sister
and me and and dad are the waves and whatnot and
you know I was like my poor father is going to
spend the rest of his life in the in this Ethan
Allen [__] sculpture like oh my God my mom said
do you want some of your dad's ashes I said [__]
yeah I got him a nice respectable very simple
wouldn't urn that I took with me to when I got my
hand and Footprints put in the semantic growman's
Chinese Theater so that my dad could be there
too and then right before I left like it wasn't
something I was planning to do but I looked down
and there was this perfect space in the cement
it's still wet you know where I put my handprints
my footprints written my name and wrote some
[__] in the date blah blah and then there was
this just empty spot and I looked at the urn it
was almost the same [__] size so I took the urn
and I put it down into the cement made a perfect
like circle from the bottom of the urn and stuff
so if you ever go see like the growman's Chinese
Theater the courtyard where all the footprints of
the famous people are the less famous Jay and
Silent bobber there me and Jason Muse right
next to each other but my father who took me to
groman's Chinese Theater when I was [__] nine
years old on a family vacation to the courtyard
and was explaining like [__] everybody who I
didn't know in the cement some people I didn't
know I was there to see the Star Wars Footprints
like R2D2 C3PO and Darth Vader and [__] and
right before we left my old man was like maybe
you'll be here one day and [__] like 40 years
later I was there so it was beautiful moment for
me to put his his ashes in the [__] cement with
me something that I could not have done if it was
just my mom's gigantic [__] dolphin urn and
stuff I shouldn't be [__] [__] talking my
mom she's in the hospital right now but she knows
how I feel about that Eric you know what you did
sorry I'm dealing with some [__] kids thank you
rain serving for letting me [__]
tell a story about my dad anyway
should we uh should we enroll the beautiful Bean
footage of JC at the celebration we should because
it'll give us six minutes to not deal with super
chat with a lot of people are so irritated by
um kids uh JC Banff man himself uh the proprietor
owner and proprietor of the scum and villainy
cantina our home for this show uh which uh even
when during a pandemic we would go to an empty
scum and villainy cantina and do the [__]
show uh if you've never been to Hollywood
make a trip just like my old man [__] took me
when I was nine years old my family and stuff
make a trip to Hollywood one day and make sure you
go to the scum and villainy cantina there ain't no
bar like it anywhere on the planet and stuff
um don't call it a Star Wars bar because now
it's a Star Trek bar they had a [__] shindig
there not too long ago for [__] uh yeah was
the show from Picard yeah and they like redid
the whole like entryway so that now it's all
like a [__] Holodeck thing or whatever it's
All Star Trek screens everywhere dope one day
JC's gonna be the richest person we know because
he's gonna franchise this [__] and there's gonna
be [__] scum and villainy Cantinas all over
the [__] world um but regardless JC Banff man
himself as you all know is a massive massive
[__] Star Wars fan so massive that he went
over to England where they're doing [__] uh
Star Wars celebration this year something that
at first I was like can you believe they moved
this [__] out of America until somebody was
like you know they made Star Wars in London at a
long time ago good point they deserve it as well
so the celebration went to the UK this year and
um uh Brian Lynch our friend Brian Lynch he went
over and stuff uh and Jason they went over as well
and so we were gonna try to do JC coming in live
um from like at one point mark was pitching it
was it was three time zones two countries one
podcast because I was supposed to be on the East
Coast Mark was going to be on the west coast and
JC was going to be over in [__] England but
as the case is me and Mark are right now both
in [__] California so we're in one time zone
and JC when we were like you ready to do this
[__] six o'clock PST [__] America time on
[__] Monday and JC was like that's three in
the morning for me okay although we got a bunch of
people super chatting this [__] pound sterling
who are obviously watching the show at [__] 3
A.M so I don't know what JC's problem is but JC
said I'm not gonna be there live but I will send
you a [__] video and [__] so JC said it was
gonna be a two minute video he turned into
a six minute video if I remember correctly
um here with a special report from Star
Wars celebration get in here dilf man
how adorable is that uh how long is that video
uh six minutes 50 seconds I believe six minutes
and 50 seconds so we're gonna go to Celebration
with our beloved Banff man who's not here because
he's over [__] in the UK and whatnot uh and
watch six minutes of video don't [__] touch
that dial because as soon as it's done me and Mark
are going to be back talking all about celebration
because we made JC promise he wouldn't spoil
everything he's there his piece is about his
personal experience and whatnot uh we'll be back
to talk about all the [__] news that came out of
Star Wars celebration including that [__]
amazing Ahsoka trailer uh which looks like [__]
Rebel season [__] five or whatever three uh as
soon as JC's done talking so without further Ado
uh jilfman take us to the UK man uh that'll give
me a chance to go take a whiz uh and and let's see
what JC has to say what's up Batman Beyond I am
here in London at Star Wars celebration it just
ended it's done it's over four days like Lightning
Fast came and went uh lots of really really cool
stuff lots of fun costumes some of my favorite uh
I saw cloud with the full-on like Kenner action
figure costume I saw a single and mace tawani
from the Ewok Adventure movie bumped into some
fat and Beyond fans who recognized me and talked
to them which I'll play those videos a little bit
later in my uh little breakdown here uh huge Star
Wars news announcements for Ahsoka and the Acolyte
and even Indiana Jones because I guess that's
Star Wars adjacent a lot of really cool vendors
um other really cool stuff uh I saw here in
London which was also wild because every time
you talk to a little kid here with the
accent they're so proper you feel like
you're talking to an adult uh that's been
wild what else some really cool scenery
um we've got an indoor bunker we've got the
Hoth turret and there's an animatronic probe
Droid that was driving around here which
was cool lots of r2d2s uh lots of Wookies
lots of mandalorians a lot of mandalorians I
also saw the first time I've ever seen this
the wet-haired Luke Skywalker in stormtrooper
outfit with a dianoga around his neck Volkswagen
was here they like wrapped some of their new
electric VW buses there was Star Wars gaming
long line if you wanted to demo the new Star
Wars miniature game that's coming out uh there
was an Ewok on a hang glider the whole weekend
that was really cool what else did we see oh uh
the emperor had his chair and was doing photo ops
with people I think my personal favorite part was
uh coming to the convention today with Jocelyn
it's just the two of us and she walked right over
to the Hasbro booth and found the Retro remakes of
the Vintage Kenner action figures and she sat down
for 10 whole minutes just looking at them and
talking about them and explaining who all the
characters were to me it honestly like it it was
uh kind of like what Ben Affleck says in Jay and
Silent Bob reboot is that uh sooner or later you
realize that you are Thomas Wayne and not Bruce
Wayne and that uh that moment uh is something
that I will carry with me uh forever because I
was doing the same thing when I was her age uh
only I was at Toys R Us uh if anybody remembers
what that is all in all a wonderful weekend with
my family a wonderful weekend with my Star Wars
family and they just announced about five minutes
ago that the next one is going to be in Japan in
two years so start saving your shekels because
we are going to Japan in 2025. uh I will be back
on fat and Beyond in two or three weeks uh when
I get back from my european vacation until then
will wil Wilkins will hold it down with Kevin
and Mark um and maybe I'll get a better haircut
by the time I come home we'll see you guys uh in
a few weeks I almost forgot here are interviews I
did randomly on the show floor from London with a
couple fat man beyond fans who recognized me from
the United States all right fat man beyond
here we are I was recognized not hard with
my stupid haircut I'm with Doug from Seattle how
has this show been Doug it's been fantastic loved
every day when did you get here we got here
Thursday so we've been here the whole weekend
and are you leaving tomorrow oh no we're gonna
stay for a few more days oh nice up our two or
R2D2 is about to run over my daughter what was
uh what's been your favorite part of the show
what have you gotten into have you gotten into
any panels yeah we got into the Soca panel and
the Overflow for badass how was the Ahsoka panel
was he crazy did people go nuts yeah it looks cool
did you did you read the heir to the Empire books
back in the day we're probably around the same age
did you go nuts when Ahsoka said heard of the
empire I didn't go nuts but I knew exactly did
you get chills a little bit did you feel like it
brought me back they they were talking to you that
they put something in there just for you that's
how I felt yeah they knew who they were hurting
all right that's it that's what we got
with Doug I'm Gonna Keep keep searching
what up everybody back with another fat man
beyond fan this is Chris from Philadelphia
Chris what was your favorite part of the
convention so far oh god dude leave that
with you uh just just walking around like
this one is actually one of my favorite ones
like that like I've been four now like what
even seven uh 11 11. since you were a child
I've been coming to this wow what what
um what's the best costume you've seen
I gotta say I I gotta send you pictures all
right we'll we'll put them up we'll put them up
what um what has been did you get any
panels did you do any panels I did do
panels I've got uh uh uh day one
I got the lucasfilm panel and uh
see seeing like uh the six minutes
of uh uh the new uh Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones footing yeah what about what
about the Ahsoka trailer how did that play but
let's try it out yeah let's effing go dude like
there it is more fat man beyond fans
and you can drink beer here good time
good time
is that we back
now I can point that way [__] I
never get this right God damn it
you I could go like that [__] him uh hold on
number one just to listen to [__] some of the
chat people who absolutely love that sequence
um somebody said that [__] where is it it wasn't
a Super Chat but it was I can't find it where is
it no here it is oh Reuben KIRO said JC should
cosplay as craglin for Guardians 3 next month
gonna do kind of did look like a man but future
uh Maya says uh Futurama yeah sorry says he looks
like the character from the first episode of
the droids cartoon he [__] did man I wonder
um how nice what a great report that
was uh from JC uh from Batman himself
and he uh he you know edited it together
and [__] while he's over there enjoying
his ass his wheel on the Fly Just swapping us
to make people feel better he's moving [__]
around he wants to put us back in our places
it feel like the beginning of The Brady Bunch
the square is moving yeah it's like I I [__]
it up because I turned off my camera when I
went to the yeah when I went to the no it's
just me I muted my camera when I went to The
Whiz Palace and then came back oh are you
muted some people are saying you're muted
yeah I was to make sure that I couldn't be
heard while JC was talking my favorite part
of me the whole thing is I'm apologizing to
the audience because you guys shifted around
didn't know why I went to go soup and ta-da
there you are they say you're still muted
don't worry about it it's a delay Mark you
can't believe the audience trust me fair enough
um so celebration let's talk about celebration
before we do that I just want to point out
tickets for fat man beyond August 25th at smog
Castle are now up as are tickets for the 826
thing that I'm not supposed to necessarily
mention but you can still buy tickets for it
I should also point out we're doing Hollywood
Babylon me and Ralph Garman at Flappers Comedy
Club this Saturday here in Los Angeles but June
2nd Hollywood Babylon traveling back to smodcast
Castle to do a show yes Ralph Garmin coming back
to New Jersey we're doing uh Hollywood Babylon
on June 2nd uh it's not up yet but red State's
going to be on June 3rd and Ralph was in that so
he's going to be there and then we're also doing
Hollywood Babylon Comic-Con theater on June 4th
that's where me and and Ralph read comic books
and Ralph does funny voices those tickets are
now on sale at smodcastlecinemas.com and then
it's modcastle keeper Ernie O'Donnell asked
me to mention one more time that this Friday kids
this Friday at smart Castle Cinemas is a night in
Mission Hill with Bill Oakley and Josh Weinstein
man the kids responsible for Mission Hill uh you
can go see that this [__] Friday right if you're
in on the east coast and you love Mission Hill
here's your chance come smilecastle and see
it kids anyway back to the Celebration and
one other thing as when we started our uh friendly
neighborhood dilfman was kind enough for mine is
that this is fat man beyond episode 398. um slash
Fat Man on Batman um all in 398 which means we are
two episodes away from 400. Batman 400 Batman 400
which we should probably make a bit of a big deal
about we should and we should do that where the
show has been live mostly of course which would
be at the scum and villainy cantina so when
JC gets back which should be soon as he said
um we'll figure out what that date is going to
be we'll put those tickets on sale for uh at scum
and villainy cantina man we should probably
do both shows live 399 and 400 but the very
least 400 has to be [__] live from the Cantina
hell yeah I wonder if we can get a special guest
who would you get if you get anybody
if we could get anybody yeah I mean
anybody I think I do my father because that
would mean he'd be alive again Victor Garber
Jesus Victor oh my God what a great answer
you know what my dad's dead and he's never
coming back but Victor Garber there's a [__] we
could talk to yeah I was I was gonna say Affleck
oh I would love to have [__] Ben Affleck on
number one we would talk about [__] Justice
League Batman v Superman we talk about his time
in the suit number two we could talk about air
which I went to the premiere of and my God it's
[__] wonderful like it's a legit wonderful
[__] movie there's no way they don't remember
this movie when it comes Oscar time [__] next
year he directed the [__] out of this movie man
and he's also legit wonderful as was the dude's
name Phil Knight in the movie like look I'm a
big Affleck fan obviously and I love Affleck
the director is absolutely wonderful and he's
way better than me at the job but Affleck the
[__] actor I've always been a fan of and seeing
him play [__] Phil Knight was delightful Maddie
Damon is [__] wonderful in the movie everyone
Pyle Davis Chris Tucker [__] Marlon Wayans uh
Chris basina like the [__] cast is fantastic
and the movie's just such a great American success
story and [__] like that if you were alive in
the 70s and 80s like me and Mark particularly
for 1984. it's a [__] fall down memory foals
like right down the rabbit hole of all my most
cherished memories of the 80s the soundtrack
plays like the most expensive 80s soundtrack
ever put together every scene has a classic song
from 82 to 84 and [__] um it also like you know
the movie that I'm making next 4 30 movie is set
in 1986. so I went to the premiere with arley's
boyfriend Austin and [__] and as we're sitting
there we're the first ones in the [__] theater
because I stopped smoking weeds and now I'm on
time for everything almost except for this show
um as we sat there alone in the [__] theater
waiting for the rest of the crowd to come you know
at premieres General they'd Play the soundtrack
while you're waiting for the movie to begin and
after like the fourth song I was like oh [__]
this is all going to be the soundtrack got to be
one of the most expensive soundtracks of all time
man but like if you're it played like my Spotify
playlist every song that I still listen to to this
day and [__] uh the movie is legit wonderful
um so happy for Ben he's a talented [__] we
all know but my God this movie is fantastic and
I'll just say that because like I know the guy
and [__] um this movie will do fine without me
I think it opened at like 12 million this weekend
or something like that yeah it open strong for the
kind of movie that it is especially considering
that like Super Mario Brothers sucked up all the
[__] money from the box so this is definitely
a kids weekend at the box office this week for
those who follow along with this sort of thing I
talked about on the last fat man beyond when we
did bumps mod Castle how [__] nobody goes to the
movies anymore uh at least mod Castle Cinemas and
[__] uh you know opening [__] night of Avatar
seven o'clock show we had 12 people opening night
of [__] Creed Three and these were movies that
were huge we had six people Super Mario Brothers
like apparently all right spot Gaza Cinemas are
like a rep house where you can watch old Kevin
Smith movies and [__] cartoons kids come
Galore to that theater so Ernie texts me on
[__] Wednesday to be like we had 200 guests
on a Wednesday I thought it was cute that he
called him guests I was like what are we [__]
Disneyland stop that [__] the customers are you
a cast member too yes oh that's good deep cut but
yeah man [__] uh Super Mario Brothers was huge
this weekend as we all probably have heard
by now and we'll continue to be [__] huge
um but air did very [__] well considering what
it is like a grown-up movie for grown-ups set in
an era that any you know most of us are
[__] middle-aged to appreciate but it's
such a well-made movie and honestly it's an
Amazon movie so it doesn't they ain't got to
worry about [__] box office and [__]
um go see it kids if you haven't seen air
[__] is worth the trip man Ben did a great
[__] job Maddie's [__] wonderful in the
movie they're all good there's all star casts
and they're all [__] fantastic that movie had
a smile on my face from beginning to [__] end
um [__] wonderful and so smart I haven't seen it
yet but I did encounter because you know of course
both Matt and Ben are out doing press for it
and I saw the greatest anecdote and it did warm my
heart a bit where it was the the screenwriter was
talking about his process like it's his first ever
produced screenplay he like excellent screenplay
by the way excellent he had the idea like a decade
ago and it was kind of like you know noodling at
him and really inspired by the Last Dance the
Michael Jordan documentary and then kind of
lit a fire in himself and wrote it and they got
in the hands of Matt you know and Ben and like
is it like when they're on set like both Matt
and better [__] Oscar winning writers and
so like they kept on adding stuff and and did
his directors pass in the script and they were
kind of improving stuff on the on the day and it's
like the script the screenplay had you know like
seven or eight voices in it and then you know the
screenwriter Adam Conner I think his name is said
that he was on set like a late in production and
Ben pulled him aside and said you know what we're
gonna We're Not Gonna arbitrate like you're gonna
have soul credit on the screenplay because this
is your idea like you're the guy who wrote the
first script like you're the guy who pulled it
out of obscurity you're the guy you're the reason
why we're all here like yeah we all helped but you
have soul screamed like credit on this movie that
we all worked on I was like you know what [__]
it that's right like that's that's the way you do
that which is yeah man you're the director you're
gonna get all the credit anyway you're getting
paid four times when that kid is getting paid
you did your work you made it great and you let
him have his moment Affleck is a classy dude he
was raised right I saw his mom at the premiere and
like last time I saw her was much heavier than I
was so I was [__] looking I went and saw Ben
and Jen and chit chatted with them and then when
I was leaving I saw Chris app like I was like oh
[__] and so I got in her eye line because she
was having a conversation with somebody and
she looked at me and then looked away and I
was like what the [__] and then I went over
and I was like mother Affleck it's it's Kevin
Smith she goes oh my where did you go and I was
like I lost a little weight and [__] like that
um she was very [__] sweet but what was my
point in telling that story oh raised right
and I told her that I was like this [__] owes
you everything he was raised by an educator and
his mom's a teacher and [__] like that so
everybody's always like yeah every once in a
while a new Affleck thing comes out and people
suddenly realize that he speaks very fluent
Spanish one of his many gifts like all week
long on the internet people are like [__]
calling him Ben call him Benito but uh his mom I
gave him credit for that and she was like Kevin I
didn't teach him Spanish I was like you taught
him [__] everything credit um somebody said
he said in who was a bonanista said is air
historically accurate Ben addressed this when
he got up to intro the movie in the beginning and
you know he said look it's pretty historically
accurate but we're making a movie here so you
know they took some Liberties and [__] like
that so you know don't go into air looking for a
historical document you know it's a he described
it as a fable he's like it's an American
Fable and he's absolutely [__] right but
there's enough historical accuracy in that movie
like to ground it to a place of like oh yeah this
is based on true events um and they they spend
like you know the first [__] four minutes of
the movie is like an 80s [__] travelogue to
set the tone of where they were at the time
and what was going on even that alone before the
movie began proper the story proper I had [__]
joker-like grin on my face just by Falling Down
the 1984 [__] Rabbit Hole of like oh my God like
it's it's a wonderful movie go see
it sweet so yes I think Ben would
be a lovely guest for a fat man 400 but
we'll think about it and we'll figure out
when exactly we're going to pull this off
once JC's back from uh Mary old England
oh dilf man what's up I just want
to point out as for guests as far
as guests go Davey sock rocker spent a buck 99
to say Kevin James but he's right here already
deep Cuts right there man since we're going back
to Super Chat Wyatt butts paid 20 bucks to say
what about a better place made by viewsq historian
uh Vincent Pereira that will be coming to smod
Castle as well Mark my goddamn words man just
like we're showing drawing flies uh on May 7th
we'll be showing a better place uh as well this
this maybe this summer I just came up with a full
summer schedule that I at three in the morning and
[__] sends it to Ernie to be like this is what
we're doing we're doing we're leaning heavily
into the movies that made me series all this
summer so we're gonna bring you [__] Goonies
we're gonna bring you [__] Beetlejuice we're
gonna we're gonna show you so many movies that you
could watch at home and we're gonna overcharge you
to watch some of this podcast Jaws we're gonna
be showing [__] Jaws coming up and stuff
uh anyway everything that's not owned by Disney
essentially yeah absolutely because kids I don't
know if you know this or not but Disney does not
like rep house they don't like you showing their
old [__] they're I guess they're [__] present
and future and [__] so Universal wonderful to
work with Warner Brothers wonderful to work
with man Warner Bros reached out and like do
you want to show Superman I was like [__] yes
so we're gonna be showing Superman the movie soon
um Paramount easy to work with uh the list goes
on Disney they won't let you [__] touch one of
their old movies man like and that includes now
the fox Library when I was on the road with the
clerks the convenience store I went to a lot of
mom and pop theaters and [__] and they were all
lamenting like the [__] loss of the fox Library
they can't show alien anymore because Disney owns
it and they threw it in the vault and even it
doesn't matter if you're like please can I [__]
you even if you're like can I show up for charity
they're like no way they don't they don't do
that they just don't play like that so like kids
movies as I said work insanely well at our theater
so Ernie has been like programmed like we had
not only did we show the Muppet movie but we had
[__] uh Muppets Take Manhattan for like a week
and it outgrossed current [__] movies and [__]
like that so Ernie was just like what other kids
movies can we show and he started listing titles
in every one of them I was like we can't show
The Aristocats that's Disney we can't show [__]
that that's Disney we can't show [__] Toy Story
That's Disney and he was like what so yes Disney
don't like to work with the rep house theaters
at all they live in the present and the future
and I don't know why they won't
[__] deal with the past but
there it is anyway speaking
of Disney and the future
um we got a bunch of [__] news we got a
bunch of first looks of stuff some of which
have seeped into the the digital ether
for all of us to watch legally some of
which uh are still behind the inside the
Disney Vault but we we got the trailer
teaser trailer whatever we're calling it
for Ahsoka which is coming this August
which we talked about earlier um and looks like
basically Rebels season whatever the [__] but
you know awesome to see it come to life number
one like you know not just because I know her but
I [__] love Rosario Dawson one of my favorite
actors on the [__] planet I was lucky enough to
get to work with her in some stuff some in clerks
too Jane zombob reboot clerked three more recently
um she absolutely destroys in this [__]
trailer she is Ahsoka and it's so [__]
wonderful we've seen her be Ahsoka in a couple
episodes in Mandalorian and [__] Boba Fett
but I can't believe and I'm so happy that they're
giving this character on series I'm so delighted
that it's Rosario Rosario who walks between all
[__] worlds man she's done DC work Marvel work
Star Wars work she wanted to do Star Trek work as
well yeah he tried to make that happen we tried to
move Heaven and Earth but we just couldn't get it
done um she's she's truly a fan I ain't even gonna
say she's a fan girl she's practically a fan boy
she loves the [__] so much she's a fan person
let's just leave it at that mom who's also [__]
one of the greatest living actors we have she's
legit [__] wonderful and everything one of my
favorite performances she ever gave was in um uh
Spike Lee's 20 25th hour one of my favorite [__]
movies of all time and stuff but she wonderful in
absolutely everything and she looks fantastic
in this movie I don't mean just the look I mean
[__] her [__] whipping those lightsabers into
the ground and doing this [__] and it's spinning
they did that once in [__] I think it was an
episode of rebels and [__] same [__] trick you
could tell Dave filoni deeply deeply involved in
Ahsoka very much so I mean it seems as if I mean
Dave filoni being now the kind of you know the the
new George Lucas for the TV stuff in in Star Wars
is the I'm I know what works I know what I love
this has all been sort of a long game so that I
could bring clone wars and Rebels to real life
and cast people who be great in it in fact cats
some of the people who did their Voice work for
the original stuff I mean grand grand Elmo thrawn
you know whatever Mickelson they they found the
the Mickelson Farm they found another Mickelson
uh Lars I believe his name is um is now who was
the voice of thrawn on the cartoons is now going
to be the live action Grand Avenue and it's not
even like they got a robot playing him and he's
doing the voice is literally him as the actor
yeah he's [__] blue and everything like that
how awesome is that man God bless Dave filoni and
his funny hat because this is a man who deeply
deeply cares about Star Wars I remember doing an
interview I think maybe it was for The Tonight
Show I forget who it was but I was interviewing
filoni and you know it was at the time where you
[__] all over the [__] uh prequels and [__]
like that and he was the first one to like stop
me dead my track's not in a shitty way to be like
[__] you but he was like you don't understand
how [__] beautiful those movies are and he
took me on a deep dive about the Lucas prequels
and [__] and he was right like he he flipped me
he flipped my script completely that was before
they gave him the [__] keys to the kingdom him
in the Fabs I love what he's [__] doing I love
the fact that he's like you know what ahsoka's
just going to be [__] rebels in live action
I love what we also heard which I guess might be
part of the news which is about what he's how he's
wrapping up Mandalorian like you got it and
it's it's really really it's both smart from
a story perspective and smart from a financial
perspective which is you can't charge people for
Mandalorian really you get the you get 14.99
to subscribe to Disney plus and there's some
merch that you can get for sure but you can't get
people to buy stuff the way you used to you can't
charge them for admission the way you used to this
way now suddenly they're making a Star Wars movie
they're making it big and now you get to make
300 400 million dollars domestically 500 600
internationally on a TV show that you were giving
people ultimately for free you know and like wrap
it all up in a movie put a nice bow on it like
tell the story of mandalore's final chapter the
story of din jarin and then young grogu not being
so young maybe learning how to speak words I don't
know any of those things are possible but women
did they say when that's happening they didn't
they didn't put any dates on it because I think
they've they've since learned their lesson do
not promise things in Star Wars land because
it's always a it's a shifting delicacy Buffet
um I think that the thing of the Ahsoka trailer
that that worked for me most was Rosario because
I never watched Rebels so like I don't have a
real connection to these characters like I know
oh that's Sabine ran and here's thrawn and there's
I'm like I don't know who any of those people
are but I know who Rosario is and I know who
asoki is and I think she's [__] she's so good
she just drags me into it even though I don't
have a real connection to it and they gave her
the billion dollar line in the trailer where she's
like where she literally says heir to the Empire
and how sweet for him like those books are no
longer Canon and [__] but now filoni found a way
to kind of bring him in and and make him Cannon he
literally had her say heir to the Empire for God's
sakes yeah that's fan service right there kids uh
you know remember earlier in the chat somebody was
like [__] on Star Wars [__] on stores I can't
when somebody this cares this much when you could
feel the fandom like and that trailer is nothing
but [__] fandom yeah like I I I spent some time
in this podcast shooting on Star Wars um In
This Very episode [__] on Star Wars um but
I I always come to these things with hope you know
because the first one of these I saw it was a New
Hope and so I come to these With A New Hope every
time because you know and hoping that they will
recapture the thing that I love about Star Wars um
it's been a while so but I I keep watching a while
um and it seems as if Star Wars is
trying their [__] best because now
um Daisy Ridley is back Ray is back the uh the
movie that we'd heard announced a couple years
ago that Damon Lindelof and Justin Gibson were
writing that uh that they have since left and
is now being written by Stephen Knight who he of
peaky blinders Fame directed by Charmaine Obed
chenoy who's behind Miss Marvel is the return of
Rey is the next chapter in The Ray story so Rey's
getting her own movie or series she's getting
her own movie they're not promising any series
of anything anymore at the very least there will
be one movie that according to Kathleen Kennedy
it's the story of the rebuilding of the new Jedi
Order and the powers that rise to tear it down Rey
will be the powerful Jedi Master rebuilding
the order so [__] yeah like wait a second
so here's my question yes sir JJ Abrams do you
get a piece of that because like he created Ray
um created Ray with a bunch of other people
I I imagine that it all belongs to Lucasville
um probably does probably does I mean I don't
know if he has some kind of you know sweeten
the pot character creation payments that he'll get
a a piece of he should he look how he he ain't on
Super Chat so I don't know how he's making it so
give him a piece of Ray God damn it Ray a drop of
golden [__] cash yeah wait so they announced
a Mandalorian movie or they're not necessarily
calling it Mandalorian movie but right but that's
Dave filoni's feature film is probably going to
sweep up the story of Mandalorian booger Boba
Fett and and I think Ahsoka let me double check
and then they also announced a ray movie then it
was a rain movie and then James Mangold announced
the third movie um which is set it's a Biblical
epic apparently um said 25 000 years before any
other Star Wars content thus far um his it's going
to wrestle with the ideas of where the force came
from when did we discover it and when did we learn
how to use it normally I would be like what but
[__] James mangle is a fantastic filmmaker I
mean looking at the new indie trailer oh my God
how good is that [__] trailer and they open with
[__] Sympathy for the Devil and [__] yeah yeah
I mean and it's it it doesn't give away very much
of what the story is no it doesn't you really
don't it's a masterful trailer in that way because
I think we all realize that they just half the
time they just tell us the movie in the trailers
here's this is the guy who made 310 to Yuma [__]
work this who made [__] Ford versus frog I
didn't give a [__] about cars man and I love
that [__] movie this is a guy who made Logan
For Heaven's Sake this is a guy what go on and
on he's honestly like the best of us I don't even
include myself as an Us in the [__] directorial
caliber of a James mangled so you tell me James
mangle is doing a Star Wars story set long before
[__] Star Wars long before the prequels long
before the [__] Force even began maybe the midi
Floridian story whatever the [__] normally
I'd be like what but it's that guy you got my
money I'm already on board this dude is a master
Storyteller it's that guy um Kate and Leopold guy
deep Cuts deep medical guts I used to work at
Miramax uh if uh if you were on the ground in
London um for celebration you got to see the first
look at the acolyte Leslie Headlands um new series
speaking of Miramax when I met Leslie Headland
she was my friend John Gordon's assistant uh
who worked at [__] Miramax back in the day and
then I remember one day and she was like hey man
I wrote a play will you come see it me and Moshi
was like Yeah and I don't think we ever did but
I've watched her quietly [__] Ascend men like I
remember she did though she wrote the about last
night remake and [__] um now she [__] doing
the acolyte which is apparently amazing based
on reaction people had yeah we're not seeing that
right they're not putting that online or anything
they haven't put it online yet um apparently it's
it's a prequel Pre-Sequel said 100 years before
um the Skywalker Saga um so it's in the
high Republic when the Jedi were just [__]
everywhere uh that Leslie Headland has described
it as Frozen meets Kill Bill in Pitch meetings
[__] yeah I mean what the [__] those
are three good words that I like Frozen
um Amanda Sternberg from um from the hate U
give and body's body's bodies is in it Lee
Jong Jae from squid game Jody Turner Smith
from Queen and slim and Manny Jacinto from
the good place and was cut out of uh top gun
Maverick are all these sort of that's the cast
that they've that they're rolling with and so
what is that for that yeah all and nothing but
positive like feedback for what they saw people
been loving yeah absolutely somebody pointed out
Chad hold on where is it uh Frasier Lomas said
Copland was great excellent [__] point James
mangle did [__] Copland as well but algae 473
says but this James Mangold know anything about
Star Wars or knowledge of Star Wars Lord James
Mangold is of a certain age I think he's younger
than me but anybody who [__] grew up in the 70s
watching these movies kids knows their Star Wars
um I don't think that dude throws a SAT into the
[__] ring like y'all saw Logan right yeah like
the man knows his his [__] he knows his lure
so I don't think he goes anywhere near Star Wars
unless he feels supremely confident I mean this
guy could get a job anywhere so he certainly don't
need to jump on the Star Wars train if he's doing
that I think it's coming from a place of Love also
he you know [__] he just did the Indiana Jones
and dial Destiny so obviously somebody there was
like hey man can you cross the street and [__]
come over to Star Wars and they're lucky to have
him that's what I say yeah you know if he's got a
story to tell I mean you know I'm not going to say
that any writer can write anything because clearly
there are people who have proclivities and talents
in one so versus another but that is a dude who
seems to like if he's interested in it he will do
deep [__] research in it and then deliver like
I don't know how much of a wolverine he was a deep
lore fan of but Logan is the best X-Men you know
like I don't know if he could give a [__] about
Ford's end or Ferraris but I love that movie yeah
it's a great movie you know and so like he just
seems to be a filmmaker who when he invests in a
thing and does the work in a thing can just find
and has a story he wants to tell can find his way
to make it work and so I'm I'm here for whatever
version that is um the funk bomb bro the game cat
said Kevin Smith needs to do a Star Wars movie no
he does not look I'm the world's biggest Kevin
Smith fan I'm here to tell you he would drop the
[__] ball don't trust Kevin Smith with a Star
Wars anything you know what Kevin Smith does
references Star Wars and movies that's the exact
level of his talent that's the glass ceiling that
he's got if they gave me the kings of the kingdom
and they were like you do whatever you want
I'm not that imaginative like when it comes
to this [__] that's where I stopped being
a filmmaker and I just resort to being a fan
that's where all this [__] came from why I
do what I do is because I grew up watching
[__] like Star Wars reading Marvel Comics
and stuff but I don't need to make that
[__] because I know my limitations and
I'm very limited kids very limited so I'm the
guy you want writing [__] where characters
talk about that [__] I'm not the guy you
want anywhere near Star Wars anything unless
in a world where they're putting Jack blacks and
lizos and [__] Star Wars things like crabs I
know a guy who's been talking about this [__]
for decades decades and you know him call anyway
um we got some updates about Andor season two
hold on is that it for the Star Wars movies
did they say anything about uh Ryan Johnson's
um according to variety um Catherine Kennedy
to give an update on Ryan Johnson I said that he
is so busy working on the next Benoit Blanc film
there might be some time before we see Johnson's
Star Wars movie I was gonna say because my man's
[__] like stars on the like Beyond on the rise
he's now legitimately part of the firmament and
[__] like that and he don't need Star Wars at
all I know some people get testy about you know
[__] The Last Jedi or whatever the [__] I
you know you know how I feel about the Last Jedi
um now between those [__] Knives Out movies
and what's the show he's doing with Natasha
Leone yeah Poker Face which everybody [__]
loves like he's an institution and he don't
even need Star Wars so naturally it'll probably
be a few years before he gets there but I think
by the time he circles back after he's done doing
all his [__] I bet you he does something [__]
special yeah you know so his movie is coming but
slowly and uh takeaway TD is also working on a
movie and according to to Kathleen Kennedy he's
still writing his script he doesn't want to bring
others into that process and I don't blame him
he has a very unique voice so we want to protect
that and that's what he's doing and we're gonna
make that one day whenever that day May Come
just said imagine if instead of Jack
Black and lizzo it was Kevin and Mark
I can't imagine that no totally I I would
happily [__] night grogu and kissy face
with Kevin as the gay world we would be the ones
jumping the [__] Mandalorian shark if you will
um but nobody calls nobody cares yeah nobody calls
we sit here and blow this [__] two hands like
the Saturday Night Live sketch um [__] every
goddamn week but Fondo ring and [__] no because
I apparently [__] on it every other week so is
that what's holding us back you could be it could
be you've hitched Your Wagon in the Millennium
Falcon right now I know guys I'm right here
uh and or season two is coming apparently uh
August 2024 is this what I read the last shot
of Andor season two goes right to the first shot
of Rogue one they consider Rogue one to be the
this and or season one and or season two and Rogue
one is a Trilogy yeah according to Gilroy he said
we know exactly where we're going you have to
you know what you have to deliver emotionally
and what the story has to do it's a decision
board of survival but it's good for us creatively
uh apparently season two will take place over four
years with each with four three episode long pods
telling a story from each year um and then it
ends with with Rogue one um I love Tony Gilroy
and I never loved him more than when he [__]
mentioned clerks in his round of press he was
just remember that scene from clerks talk about
the Star Wars contractor Death Star contractors
and I was like what the [__] like did he [__]
just say what I thought he said it was very sweet
of him man uh Star Wars obviously is a phenomenon
that influenced a great deal of my work to have
somebody in Star Wars even [__] give me the
tiniest [__] like oh yeah there was a bit of
influence there was like [__] breathtaking to
me that being said I still haven't watched all the
indoor season one I will do so good so good that's
why I hear from literally everybody everybody's
like dude it's the best Star Wars that has existed
in a while so I look forward to finishing it nice
um two more little bits out of uh celebration um
tales of the Jedi is getting um a second season
Dave filoni sort of Anthology just kind of telling
little stories in and around the the continuity
wait what's that tales of the Jedi did you not
see season one of tales of the Jedi the animated
thing yes yes so what Dave filoni did that yeah
and now he's going to season two in season two
um and also a season two of the Star Wars Visions
Anthology which was Star Wars is interpreted by
various animation houses from all over the world
is coming back for season two on May the 4th
um and one of the ladies judging about the trailer
which did drop one of the animation houses that's
doing a Star Wars short is ardman who did the
Wallace and Gromit cartoons and chicken and
Chicken Run and Flushed Away yes yes the
great [__] artman Studios oh awesome so
they're going to do stop motion claymation
it looks so cool kids remember when clerks
came out if you were alive and they would they
talked about the Death Star contractors when I
when I wrote that scene it was like oh man
remember Star Wars because we never thought
we were getting another Star Wars thing ever
again now all the Star Wars things they will
they will never not be a star war between now and
the time me and Mark leave this [__] Festival
they're gonna there's gonna be Star Wars forever
man it's never gonna stop like it's and I'm here
for it you know it's and some people get kind
of stinky about it and [__] hey man make all
the Star Wars you can because some of it will be
great some of it would just be okay but you know
what as a kid who grew up watching this [__] I'm
here for it I know some people are like you can't
get nostalgic for something if it won't go away
it's never going away and I'm I'm okay with that
um one other piece of Star Wars news um that did
not come from celebration would drop just before
it is Donald Glover according to an interview
with GQ Magazine said that he is more than open
to playing Lando calrizine again which I hear has
happened right I mean you know according to him
um it's gonna love to play Lando again it was
fun time to be in it just needs to be the right
way to do it um since the pandemic he's he's not
interested in doing anything that's just going
to be a waste of my time or just a paycheck I'd
rather spend time with people I enjoy but he has
been talking to lucasfilmer about playing Lando
again saying Landon was definitely somebody I'd
like to hang out with we're talking about
it but that's as much as I can say without
Kathleen Kennedy hunting me down I'm here for it
man I thought he did a great job as Lando but if
you come to Orlando something I hope to God it
starts with Billy D Williams Lando reminiscing
about his younger days so that we get to see
him and then we get to see uh Donald Glover and
like young Indiana Jones but with Lando people
with Lando young Lando Calrissian just do that
um leaving uh a galaxy far far away
and returning to our current one
um Harry Potter uh seems to
be shifting into television
um the long rumors who knew who knew I mean look
we always knew that [__] once they made money
they're like all right here's Fantastic Beasts
and we always knew they had like [__] the cursed
child waiting in the wings that they could always
do but I this is why I'm [__] an idiot not a
visionary I'm like well Harry Potter's done they
did those movies they'll never do them again and
now they're like you're out of your [__] mind do
you know how many Batmans there have been you know
how many Spider-Mans there are I guess how many
Harry Potters are gonna be before you drop dead a
lot so now they're talking about doing a series on
HBO Max or whatever they wind up calling it yeah I
mean HBO Max potentially my if I had to guess I'd
say it's actually gonna end up being HBO proper
um but uh but yeah and the idea the general
idea is for each season of the potential TV
series to focus on one book in the Harry Potter
book series which consists of seven novels
I I would think that there's an entire generation
of kids who are like sacrilege because Daniel
Radcliffe is the only Harry Potter but you know
as we've seen if it makes a dime it will never
end kids own your childhood like they own ours
so I guess it makes sense I mean think about
it those movies you're putting like [__] all
those stories into like two hour blocks two and
a half hours sometimes almost three but the
chance to actually [__] go deep like balls
deep with an episode The episodic nature uh that
covers literally everything in the [__] books
you know makes sense I you know I I would have
never thought of it but I'm not very Visionary I
made three clerkses so I I gotta imagine somewhere
somebody was like wait we could [__] do all the
books as opposed to just [__] sections of the
book man we can go balls deep in the shin that's
what looks like what's gonna happen so get ready
for it you can't escape Harry Potter no I mean I I
100 get it you know that there was always going to
be another boy who lived even though the current
boy who lived is whatever 32 years old um it's
weird that they're just retelling the same stories
um that's the odd part like when you get
a new Indiana Jones when you get a new
Batman you get a new James Bond they're
not just remaking the old stuff that you
already saw once true and they've never
remade Star Wars they keep adding to it
it's not like like remember Star Wars well here's
the 2023 version of it same [__] story a new
hope they keep holding on to their mythology but
this you're right this is literally retreading
the same story this is like the road I'm not
putting it in the same class but you know how
they remade RoboCop like that's that's what's
going on here where they're just like oh we're
remaking it but we're just making it longer and
you can watch it on TV which I guess makes sense
um speaking of uh how much you want to bet though
that they do the series and then the [__] final
books are movies or whatever the [__] they're
gonna take their cues off of whatever happens
with Dave filoni wrapping up the Mandalorian with
its own [__] feature you better bet that [__]
Warner Brothers is going to be like oh yeah it's
a CV series until it's a [__] movie we can make
a billion dollars off of them to wrap this all
up once we you know the first [__] taste is
not free we all pay for HBO Maxwell some of us
do um but the [__] when when it comes to the
end they're gonna probably make you shell out
to go see it in the movie theater that would
be my guess but you know what I'll probably be
dead by the time this all ends because how many
books they got seven books seven books by the
time they get started let's say it's like two
years from now I'll be 54 seven books that
takes me to 61. for sure I'll be dead I'll
never be the end of this [__] thing you see how
enthusiastic I get about all this my heart races
and whatnot I'm a heart attack victim and whatnot
I got heart ailments I'll probably be dead by the
time this all happens but I'm happy to know it
exists you know I think that I think they'll do
it fast enough that you'll probably get to see it
because whatever kids they cast you'll probably
want to be the kids that are in it that's such
a good point I was thinking about it today I was
like boy they gotta [__] make that show like
because those kids will hate yeah kids do that
you know unless they find some kids from another
world who stay the same age and [__] and older
they stay the same age yes they do uh they have to
[__] keep it in real time because kids get older
man yeah I mean look at the stranger things kids
we're all now like 28 in their 20s they all got
[__] mortgages and homes like you still going to
high school yeah man like you can't like I bet you
well I mean look they got the books it's not
like they're like what's the story gonna be right
um and it sounds like she's involved JK Rowling
he has to be that's her contractors they can't
do anything without her so maybe before they
shoot if maybe they're gonna do it like David
Lynch did the Twin Peaks Series where he's
like here's the script it's a 900 page script
and we're gonna shoot the whole thing at once
that would make sense but man oh man those kids
whoever they get those kids are gonna miss out on
a [__] childhood I'll tell you right now because
they believe in the inside of that [__] brick
building they're gonna leave rich but they're
[__] Never Gonna experience life because they're
gonna have to make Harry Potter every day for like
at least six years straight if not seven yeah
you know it's going to be the same thing with
the Game of Thrones kids right like you know Arya
Stark and easy Williams was what like 12 or 13
when they started and was 25 when they wrapped up
and like find these kids who can play Young for a
long time because they're going to be working
for a long time long time um speaking of kids
uh who grew up and are growing out of their roles
uh Netflix has found a solution to their stranger
things issue I mean not the least of which is that
the upcoming fifth season is going to be the end
of it but now there's an animated stranger thing
of things that is spinning out of it I'm sorry
so season five which is that hasn't happened yet
it's coming correct that's going to be the end of
stranger things that's the end of stranger things
and now they're gonna do an animated series yep
uh according to The Duffer Brothers uh we've
always dreamed of an animated stranger things
in the vein of the Saturday morning cartoons
that we grew up loving um and to see this
dream realize it's been absolutely thrilling
we couldn't be more Blown Away the scripts in
our work are incredible and we can't wait to
share more with you the Adventure Continues
um we want to talk about some poor kids who've
been locked in a [__] brick building for
the last few years those Duffer Brothers man
yeah all they do is stranger things and they
got no choice it's their their [__] baby and
stuff and but boy they've been working on that
since it before we all saw it and [__] like
that what will they follow it up with I wonder
um well their their production company
signed a massive overall deal with Netflix
um they are adapting they have plans
to adapt as TV series Death Note
um the manga slash anime series uh as
well as Stephen King's The talisman
there you go we got an answer look at that I
was wondering Mark filled in the blanks that's
when you come to the show for knowledge
knowledge knowledge knowledge is power
um we got two more stories um one of them is
uh fun and the other one is intensely Less Fun
um Ryan coogler apparently wants to reboot The
X-Files let him let out of the [__] Storyteller
who's standing in his way apparently nobody
according to Chris Carter who created The X-Files
um Creed and black panther director Ryan cougar
is looking to be at the helm of this new project
the new take on the series which Carter refers to
as a remount uh is is an apparent departure from
the X12 Albuquerque an animated comedy spin-off
that Carter was supposed to produce in 2020.
um blah blah blah let's see you know what I
say to that I say everybody clap your hands
clap clap clap your hands I would love to see more
X-Files and I would love to uh Ryan coogler has
not let us down once no it's not even here
for once so give them all the X-Files will
there be Mulder and Scully or no uh it does not
seem that'll be Mulder and Scully um according
to Carter's quote I spoke to a young man Ryan
coogler was going to remount The X-Files with
a diverse cast so he's got his work cut out for
him because we covered so much territory I mean I
guess technically he is a young man but how weird
to it's like when we were like this kid Tim Miller
about life the guy into Deadpool is older than us
yes this young man um and now for the it's hard
to call his bad news um but the great Al Jaffe of
Mad Magazine Fame passed away at 102 years old are
you [__] me yeah 100 I mean look [__] nobody
likes to lose anybody but a hundred and two for
the man the fold in the man behind the folder um
uh the organ organ failure is the cause of death
um after celebrating his 102nd birthday last
month wow um 102 102. this man was responsible
for so many happy moments in my childhood
I was an Ardent Mad magazine reader and fan
um it was weird that I didn't engage as much with
the Mad Magazine TV show The Mad Show I was on it
once but like as much as I loved Mad Magazine
I mean nothing comes close I could still sing
it's uh great big beautiful wonderful incredible
super spectacular day one of the albums they gave
away mad super special um and Al Jaffe seeing
his drawing seeing his very singular artwork
um throughout all of my childhood and
well into my [__] adulthood as well
always made me happy this man was a
gifted artist and a funny one at that
um who holds a special place in my heart with
Don Martin [__] Severin guy that worked for
like crack magazine he started at [__] or was
it crazy cracked um all those [__] people of
my childhood that like wrote you know the humor
magazines you know National Lampoon came later
when it was more grown up and stuff but as a kid
[__] now jeffy's name was like as a rock star
name in my world still to this day and I'm sad
that he's gone but I'm happy to know that he lived
to be a hundred and [__] two years old I've
been [__] two um the first fold-in was in 1964.
um inspired according to to jaffee by the
centerfolds and Playboy and other magazines um and
let's see a four volume hardcover box set called
The Man folding collection 1964-2010 was published
uh about 10 years ago by Chronicle Books um his
final fold-in was published in the magazines
August 2020 Jaffe tribute issue and services
farewell upon his retirement at age 99. he
was still he drew a [__] fold in at age 99 well
he stopped drawing in 99. it was drawn six years
before he initially to be published as death the
unfolded illustration depicts mad mascot Alfred E
Newman beneath a slew of bad news out of business
signs when folded these sides instead read no
more new Jackie foldings with a peaceful looking
portrait of jappy of Jaffe floating Above The Fray
that's beautiful and so what they published
it long before his death so he got to see it
published he got he got to see it published um
he created more than 500 back cover fold-ins
um covering things from Jesus Christ from Bill
Mania to president Donald Trump's proposed
health care plan wow man that guy that guy
kept working yeah that's recent history
in a in in 2016 he was recognized by
the Guinness World Records as a longest
working cartoonist in comics history
did he did they list anything else he
did and are we forgetting like he did he do
Snappy answers to stupid questions he did
indeed and uh let's say remember my childhood
I remember yeah he started it mad in 1955 he
briefly left work left there to work on uh the
short-lived humbug human magazine he returned
in 58 and yes he contributed the popular
features Snappy answers to stupid questions
Legend absolute [__] Legend and he deserved to
live as long as he lived I mean unless you know
that was painful or whatever the [__] because he
that guy deserves no pain whatsoever I'm sorry his
organs shut down but my God [__] hey I don't
know what is responsible for us somebody in the
chat said we need to accept Jesus as Lord
or whatever earlier on I don't know about I
can't speak to how we're here why we're here and
[__] who put us here if anybody did but I think
whatever good Lord or [__] force of the
universe is out there that led a man who
brought brought that much [__] Joy palpable
joy in this world let him live to be a 102.
nobody wants to die I don't think um and I'm
glad he didn't for a long long ass time [__]
I hope those last years weren't
as you know [__] terrible as
as it can be when you know in a world where your
[__] organs shut down I'm [__] man he just
missed them finding the Cure keep reading about
their finding the cure for death they're going to
be able to prolong Our Lives even more guy like
that would have deserved another [__] 20 man
all those mad artists and writers you know made
me so happy throughout my childhood part of what
I do today you know in my creative DNA you'll
find a lot of Mad Magazine and whatnot Jane
Silent Bob Strike Back what is it if not a a mad
movie special for heaven's sakes I mean it's kind
of like the Muppet movie with dirty words in
it but it owes a lot to Mad Magazine and I owe
a lot to Al Jaffe he always put a [__] smile
on my face just when you were done with [__]
Mad Magazine they had one more [__] joke
and that was the fold-in and let's be honest
most of us started with the folded anyway uh
pour one out for the great Al Jaffe [__]
yeah um yes Matt will post in the in the
chat is like they're finding a cure for death
yeah every once in a while I read that online and
I graze the article and I'm like [__] hey do it
do it in my lifetime I mean look finding the
cure for death would be great finding the cure
to stop [__] aging would be even better
because I don't want to look like you know
what you don't see right here kids is I uh I if
you came in late I was uh busy doing [__] uh
Silent Bob earlier today and uh Emily who does
my makeup and [__] she colored in all my
whites that normally would see my beard so if
I look particularly young that's you know the
[__] Glory of makeup and [__] like that
the whites are moving in they're gentrifying
the [__] out of my face and I can't stand it
um it's it's unavoidable ages unless somebody
[__] cures it because I would like to be
this age forever I always thought I would
have liked to be 18 forever and [__] but 52
is not [__] bad man uh no I remember reading
something God it was a couple years ago that was
just saying that like they don't really know why
people die of natural causes like they're
never they're never entirely sure what
the medical reason for it is other than it
just happens all the time 100 of the time
um people die but they're like yeah the
body technically should not run out of gas
you know like we can replace most of it if we need
to like we can give you new heart we can give you
we can give you a transplant we can rebuild your
knees we can give you pacemakers we can you know
we can get you new we can [__] take you into
the shop and give you an entirely new innards but
why do people still die anyway and they just don't
have an answer for that and so I think that's the
Cure quote unquote cure they're trying to figure
out it's just an answer to that question of why
why even if we replace everything you're still
going to pass away uh in chat Jim Tomlin says
nothing on Super Mario Brothers we did kind of
talk about it how much money it made and stuff
like that and it's probably going to wind up being
the highest grossing film at smod Castle Cinemas
by tenure the movie just keeps making [__]
money for us particularly we get a lot of kids
in Atlantic Highlands at smart Castle Cinemas
uh but I haven't seen it and Skippy Mark didn't
see it so much more we can't say about it other
than until we see it uh we did talk about it so
I also wonder like I know that La USD is the
school district the like second biggest school
district in the country in Los Angeles was on
spring break last week and so if you're gonna open
a [__] movie the best time to open a kids movies
when kids are not in school I don't know how much
around the country that spring break happened to
sync up I don't know what jerseys was like but
um but that would explain some of the reason why
it did gross as much as it did uh Gina Ziegler who
goes to like all of our [__] mod Castle events
man she's a a smog Castle keeper right next to
Ernie O'Donnell she said that's been packed at
smodcast Castle she talked about Super Mario
Brothers deep lying man like like I said earlier
in the show smodcast keeper Ernie O'Donnell texted
me in the middle of the night to tell me how
[__] good how great that Super Mario Brothers
did on the Wednesday opening its mod Castle we may
build a [__] statue to Super Mario Brothers It's
mod Castle Cinemas because that's the only movie
[__] have come out to see other than us showing
like Mall Rats and stuff like that see now you
should you should program in the old Super Mario
Brothers but don't tell people who made that
I mean I feel like there was a new line movie
um maybe I saw an article I guess it was in
variety or something where they talked to the
directors I mean those poor sons of [__] I think
they're a married couple they took a lot of [__]
when that movie came out back in the day but they
just showed it out here at Quentin's uh Cinema
the new Beverly you know he loves Prince and they
still got a print of that movie and stuff do you
know there was no print ever made of Tusk because
we shot digitally and [__] you know blah blah
but Quentin called and requested he was like can I
make a print of tusk and that ain't cheap anymore
to make a print you know it used to be like two
three grand back in the day now it's one long
[__] effect shot but he's such a Michael Parks
fan that he was like I want to print and because
he don't show digital at his theater and you know
they used to back in the day but he won't do it
anymore he's got like a massive [__] library of
35 millimeter so um he he was on his podcast with
Roger Avery talking about talking up the Super
Mario Brothers movie and then they showed it at
the new Beverly to a packed house and [__] and
the article and variety was very warm talking the
directors who were like you know Quentin likes
it and he said nice things about him they went
to the screening and they were like everybody
was laughing in all the right places it's nice
when [__] could get a second bite of the Apple
because boy they they took it on the yoga hoser's
chin back when that movie came out gives me
hope that one day people will be like yeah
yogers wasn't that bad I doubt it but it gives me
hope everything comes around true everything fine
that's the end of the news my friend that's it
that's it yeah two hours and 45 minutes so much
[__] news oh my God give it up for Mark Bernard
and for giving you all the news in chat is there
anything we missed that you guys [__] wanted
to what the [__] is this poisonous plants 15
said did you guys discuss Clayface potentially
being the villain in the Batman 2 is that a thing
somebody being like discussed I hope so that'd
be [__] wonderful but I don't know how they do
that because he he likes doing that [__] real
right like [__] that Batman the Batman was all
about how [__] close to reality so I don't know
how to get away with Clayface unless they do the
uh Boris Carlo version of the character
who is a guy an actor and [__] like
that as opposed to the hulking [__]
Clayface um that we missed I can't imagine
that you know one thing that I didn't mention
when I was at the Overlook Film Festival I
got to see Renfield oh [__] what yeah that
was uh the opening night film of the festival
was Renfield and it's super fun it is super
fun like best casting on the planet a [__]
Nicholas Cage is just going for it you know in
every way you want Nicholas Cage to go for it
um and Nick Holt is uh is is amazing I mean
the thing about the movie is and I'm not going
to spoil very much but I think it's there in the
trailers is that it's a real it's just a big gloss
on codependency it's a big gloss on a guy who's
got a domino boss one of my favorite subjects
as of late codependency you know who just feels
like he can't live without him and so he'll do
anything to please him and but he's awful for him
you know like there's no nothing good comes from a
relationship for Renfield between him and Dracula
but he can't leave and so making it about that is
actually really smart and and all of the ways you
get to play that kind of relationship Dynamic is
really really well done there's another kind
of place Renfield it's the Beast yeah it's the
Beast it's uh it's nux he's shining in Chrome
into into Valhalla um that's right yeah oh my
God you're right and the above there's many
other things the titular boy and about a boy
um and also wasn't he in that Catherine the Great
series or whatever the [__] that's great great
yeah um very talented and it's super gory but not
like scary gory but just like pulpy gory and how
how great is Nick Cage he's he's he went full
cage I already shaved his teeth down I mean he
might have shaved his teeth down to like put in
the appliances that are his teeth but like those
ain't those teeth that's some [__] up makeup
[__] there um but I love the fact that we're
kind of coming back to realizing exactly how
amazing an actor Nicholas Cage is yes you know
because he was in the in the wild for a while like
he would just do whatever like you want me to do
this direct-to-video thing over here sure you want
me to be in the in this dumb weird ass movie that
nobody's gonna see that we shoot in Bulgaria
for 87 sure I just gotta work and then kind
of the Mandy stuff came back around and then like
Colorado space came around and pig came around and
people beginning to realize like this brand of
weird is a thing that you can actually kind of
Channel and bottle and when you can uncork it the
right way it's phenomenal it's mod bless Panos
cosmatos for casting a cage in Mandy I I'm not
going to say that's where he [__] The Comeback
began but like he got he got Nick Cage to Nick
Cage and and was the movie you did recently with
uh uh Pedro Pascal the [__] oh unbearable
unbelievable weight of unbearable genius or
something wonderful absolutely wonderful [__]
enjoyable ass movie well made funny as [__] like
and to say only Nick Cage could do it is you know
[__] an understatement to say the least man
um Nick Cage one of my favorite actors going
way the [__] back to Valley Girl which is
having its 40th anniversary uh this year and they
asked me to moderate a q a at the Chinese Theater
I don't know if they've announced this yet but if
they haven't they better announce it soon because
it's coming up um April 27th I think it is like
I'm leaving cinemacon a day early so I can come
back here and moderate the valley girl screening
I don't know if Nick Cage is going or not I don't
know who's involved but they were like we hear you
like it I was like [__] yeah I love that movie
it's one of my favorite movies of all time this
movie that taught me about love amongst many other
movies and stuff um but that one especially
that was my Romeo and Juliet God damn it oh
um and he was he's go watch that movie if
you haven't seen valley girl ever or lately
you're talking but you can see from that movie
that that dude was the man to watch and I have
watched him ever since then my whole career um
he's been many things but [__] he'll always
be Randy in valley girl to me so [__] I told
him when I did I moderated I interviewed him at
Sundance when I was doing IMDb interviews and
I also was the moderator on a Mandy screening
that him and Panos went to and stuff and I got
to tell him I was like bro everything I know
about being a guy involved with a girl I pretty
much stole from [__] valley girl and that's
you and he was like oh Kevin University
and then he [__] complimented Tusk bro
before it was fashionable he was like and let me
say Tusk and he said some nice [__] about Tusk
up my heart [__] I almost vomited my heart
up here is it because I was like a man whose
work I've always loved and [__] like literally
loved us believe me if I make a Tusk sequel one
of the first [__] phone calls I'm making is
to Nick Cage but he'll probably be too big now
to do a Tusk thing but he was a big fan of Michael
Parks I think that's why he watched the movie but
he loved it he may be a big fan of Justin long as
well got engaged to Lois Lane did you see that no
yeah so uh um Lois Lane from uh you know uh what
was the Superman movie called Superman Returns
um oh what is the actual name oh my God hey
Boswell Kate Bosworth I was like yes he's been
[__] in love for a while now and [__] and
he put up an Instagram post about like [__]
them getting engaged and [__] and then I saw it
I said I [__] put in my comments I was like she
said walrus yes which is deep you know [__]
Tusk um so happy for him he's such and happy
for her because let me tell you something Justin
long is a [__] catch man like I you know I love
my wife but I'd leave her for Justin long he's
[__] the ideal man because he's funny as [__]
talented as [__] and I think he I bet you I bet
you ten thousand dollars he's a hell of a lover
hmm uh he seemed like a very nice dude when I
met him uh uh when we did um what's him called
Family Feud Family Feud I know he kicked our
asses him and his whole [__] team and [__]
yeah oh he's he's I love Justin long to death even
one of my favorite actors on the planet and very
much like a Nick Cage where it's just like he
[__] commits and does [__] nobody else does
um what is that [__] movie he
was just in Barbarian such a great
[__] flick um but anyway congratulations and
congratulations congratulations no I was right
congratulations now that I'm not stoned all
the time I'm like is that the right word
um congratulations to the great Justin long and
capable man I don't know which one made out better
in that relationship look him I know and her I
just know her work and I will say this she was
a she's [__] lucky woman to snap that guy up
he's a catch anyway anyway so uh so yeah that's
the news that's all we got to say um Redden field
is also fantastic so I think it's up it's Friday
so uh so yeah go see it I can't wait I'm hoping
that he shows up for that Valley Girl screening
um uh and you know it's in town so maybe he will
especially with Renfield being so huge and stuff
um but fingers crossed all right kids good God so
much news we did it for hours and hours and hours
and that means there's only one part left to the
show and ladies and gentlemen you know what that
part is oh somebody said hold on and things we
missed they were like what about [__] uh um
uh Scott Pilgrim they're doing a Scott Pilgrim
cartoon is that correct indeed for Netflix yeah
so [__] let me tell you something I got
the entire cast back that was a that was
pretty astounding but you know those kids
all love that [__] movie and God bless
him for standing by when the movie came out
you know I remember Edgar bless his heart
like you know it was hurting at the box office he
stayed with that [__] movie he went everywhere
with that movie he [__] stood by it believed in
that goddamn movie and then that movie of course
had its bucket you know very quickly once it went
to home video that's when [__] its audience
founded I guess and [__] people absolutely
adored so I'm happy for them and they've got
a cartoon coming their way indeed um and then
somebody else asked about another thing let me see
um I don't know but we pretty much hit everything
[__] man I mean you heard all that news oh
dilf what do you got well I'm just saying are
you actually gonna ask for Q a when like the
entire opening of the show for like 30 minutes
was q a are you kidding me in a world where
they're paying for Q a on Super Chat [__] yes
we'll take all their goddamn questions man uh wait
stay uh EC Rose said did you talk about the Barbie
movie trailer we didn't we did not certainly is
a trailer yeah so I'm here I'll be honest with
you I haven't seen it yet I saw all the [__]
pictures online but I've I have not seen the
Barbie trailer yet I will I look forward to it
I love both of those kids Margot and [__] too
simulu is in it um yeah I mean it's it's
Shang Chi yes in the Barbie trailer he's in
the Barbie movie I'm sorry it took me this long
to remember Ryan Gosling that's his last name
Canadian boy's last name what a great
there's another [__] great actor man
and funny as [__] do you ever see him on
SNL like anybody who goes to SNL and kills
earns my [__] lifelong respect and
I know he's a wonderful actor and he's
always been wonderful and everything but
like seeing that dude [__] crush on SNL
does my heart good man yeah did you see this
weekend with Molly Shannon yes and I was so
[__] happy for her uh yeah her big return
she did oh come on it's Molly Shannon man
how could she not do well and she resurrected
that character that comedian character that's
like can I tell you have you seen this uh
Genie Janine Dorsey I forget what her name is
um all right somebody said Kevin doesn't see
things anymore Benjamin said that I do I see
a lot of things I just haven't seen the [__]
Barbie trailer um Scott Pilgrim is in Barbie too
what do they mean by that [__] Michael Sarah's
and Barbie yeah he's got a massive cast I love
iron in it so what the [__] um I love Michael
Sarah man Michael Sarah of course I love him from
Arrested Development and other things he's done
but one of my favorite Michael Sarah roles is in
Molly's game movie with Jessica Chastain where
he essentially plays Toby Maguire and [__]
like Michael Sarah has always been like sweet
Michael Bluth kid but [__] man and of course
he's been Scott Scott Pilgrim but him as [__]
you know the poker player with no soul whatsoever
he pulled that [__] off I watched that movie
a lot and he's so [__] great in that movie
um anyway anyway Josh mundahl who [__] paid way
too much money to ask questions in Super Chat said
this free thing Gosling the nice guys that shows
his comedic chops exquisitely when exactly Josh
he literally does like an Abbott and Costello when
he's next to the tree and there's a dead guy next
to him he's like and [__] like that oh my God
he's so [__] good in that movie excellent call
uh okay I guess are there any real questions
are they just shouting things in the chat
uh no I mean these now there are people
just I was seeing if like we missed anything
Dungeons and Dragons you see it I did see it
and did we talk about it or no I don't think
we did I think we did uh I I dug it you know like
Chris Pine is doing a lot of heavy lifting in uh
in that movie and he's so Charming [__] one of
my favorite current actors working today man that
him out years ago was that movie he did smoking
and I remember like before that movie came out he
was like bro there's a guy I worked with he's
got his name and he told his Christmas and he
goes this kid is [__] phenomenal and when I saw
the movie I was like oh [__] he's right he is
really good then he became [__] Captain Kirk
yeah um he was like you know the best part of
Wonder Woman 84 when he was like do people wear
parachutes nowadays like his his delivery is so
[__] good man and his dad was that dude from
chips the boss on chips yeah yeah yeah that's
a great great [__] actor anyway so he's good
in this movie he's very good he's very really
Charming it's a ton of fun like it's not deep
but it's also not aiming for depth you know it
it tells some very predictable kind of character
stories but it's um it does what you wanted to
do which is not give you the feeling of playing d
d because I don't think that's a that's possible
um but it's just it's a [__] Adventure you
know it's just this little Lark where we're
just we're traction off into the wild to you
know save the guy's daughter from the evil who's
he wants and there's dragons and there's
Dungeons and there's evil sorceresses and
yeah I mean it's it's not there's not a ton to say
it's just fun uh Michael Morales and chat said the
one and he's not the only one who brought this
up so apologies to whoever else brought this up
the one and only return is coming back to theaters
for its 40th anniversary smodcast Castle screening
this is the first I'm [__] hearing about it
so we were just talking about how Disney has
evolved and they won't [__] let anything out do
you mean to tell me they're going to re-release
[__] Return of the Jedi in theaters did you hear
this yeah for its 40th anniversary when's that may
um when they used to open every Star
Wars movie in May yeah it would be
it would be man if they give us half a [__] shot
you better damn skippy believe we'll be showing
[__] Return of the Jedi it's mod Castle Cinemas
go to smartcastlecinemas.com and look at the
coming soon section man there's a kind of a ton
of cool [__] coming up but oh my God I mean look
I was gonna show them what is it April 28th I was
that's coming up man it's two weeks I gotta get in
touch with small Castle keeper Ernie O'Donnell and
make sure that he [__] programs that and [__]
um and I'll be there I think April 28th I think
I'm around for some other [__] going on at
that point uh let me tell you man [__] I
was gonna show it anyway [__] Disney but
now that they're legit yeah don't tell them
that but now that they're legitimately letting
it go back to theaters [__] yeah
it'll be at smodcast Castle Cinemas
God yes if they give us half a
[__] chance give us a chance Disney
um okay um shall we q a it up if we have some cues
that we haven't already ate William coats Smith
is stuck on the f word you're just noticing
now I've been doing this job 30 [__]
years uh all I know how to say is [__]
um and all I know how to do is [__] too
I could testify to that yes dilfman sure can
tell us stealth man what brings you into these
proceedings uh well aside from all the wonderful
people that are probably gonna super chat now I do
have if you want them to ask the these questions
three I didn't what you picked them yeah I picked
them at random I'm like oh that's cool did you
pick them from Super chat or were you charismatic
super chatter in there look at you but you kept so
one from a super chatter and two from the normal
ass plebs who don't pay for questions well yeah
because they were good questions I thought I I
could be proven wrong within moments oh [__] man
somebody just paid 220 something what's that what
dollar figure is that wow I'm guessing it might
be something from the Indian area with INR in it
says we want Kevin's rrr review please make
it happen Mark he needs to see this and we
fans need to see him gush about it oh Cameron
um somebody just said before Kevin doesn't see
anything anymore and that's not true but you're
right about this because I have not seen RR I've
come very close a few times based on Mark's
Beyond enthusiastic review of it holy [__]
um so I I will get to it promises I'm gonna get
to it man uh you know I watched last night I mean
this is so not [__] you know from our world of
genre but [__] Emily the criminal with Aubry
Plaza was it good such a good [__] movie she's
like legit man like you know I know everyone loves
around like Parks and Rec and [__] like that
but like it was a damn good movie and here's
one other thing we should talk about but I don't
want to spoil it but I gotta [__] say something
is anyone watching succession I I have never
watched succession so you're you're safe with
me I'm with that dude you [__] neither of you
have watched succession I've heard it was like I
was gonna get into it I heard it the last
season so I'm like I'll wait this show it
has come out it is the last season but they
did a [__] thing on last night's episode
unbelievable and one of the best episodes of
Television I ever saw um my God the acting on
this show is [__] phenomenal and uh I think
the guy's name is Jesse Armstrong who created
It Maybe I'm Wrong took a bold [__] choice
and Ram with it and it [__] paid off like it
was it was just [__] incredible um if you're
not watching succession if you haven't watched
succession like these [__] numb nuts get get to
HBO [__] or HBO Max wherever the [__] they run
it I watch it on HBO Max and watch the [__] out
of it man it's phenomenal and the last an episode
they did last night was [__] spellbinding
a spellbinding piece of drama turgey kids
fair I don't want to spoil anything but [__] it
ain't look it ain't just all cousin Greg I love
[__] Nick and he's amazing on that show but for
everybody on that in that show everybody in the
cast is just [__] mind-bendingly good um and
and yeah [__] the Culkin kid [__] Brian Cox
Brian Cox the original [__] Hannibal Lecter
Manhunter um uh Jeremy what's his name Jeremy
maybe I'm wrong I don't know if I can look oh
they're all [__] great in the show uh but man
they did an episode last night where I was like I
can't believe uh [__] I can't believe what they
did it was astounding in any event back to the
original question I will watch [__] rrr you
should it's great um okay uh stealth man who is a
real big [__] Super Chat snob and [__] and he
said it's going to ruin the show and he's probably
right [Music] um is taking the job seriously he's
picked three questions from the audience only one
from Super Chat uh [__] two from the normal ass
people who've supported this show forever and
whatnot uh he's gonna bring us into the Q a man
which may go longer than three questions because
if I see [__] serious money going up on that
Super Chat you better believe I'm gonna answer
that question hold on let me flip that switch
real quick yeah and it'll just be Kev here's
[__] answering questions like going on hour five
um Josh mundahl backs me up with a super chat
4.99 but he don't have to pay more he [__]
overpaid us before he said succession is what
billions could have been I only watched season
one of billions and I kind of fell off not
because it was bad just because like there
were other things to watch he says if you're
into a very Sorkin Style Show I don't even know
if I would consider succession a Sorkin Style
Show I don't mean to argue with somebody who's
put so many [__] dollars into the Super Chat
tonight but it's succession is really quite I
saw somebody describe it as like [__] Dallas or
Dynasty in the current age but it ain't that it's
it's I don't know how to describe it except I've
I've never enjoyed watching rich people on TV I'm
not like one of those people like my mom when
we used to watch Dynasty when I was a kid she
just you know oh my God look at the wealth like
she didn't give a [__] about the story man she
was all about how rich everyone was and [__]
this is one of the only [__] stories about
rich people that I've ever enjoyed in my life
um but I don't even know if that's the right
way to sell it it's just a great piece of drama
just setting the world of the [__] sickly rich
uh anyway over to delft man sitting in for
Banff man who is over in the UK If You're
joined us late Banff man did a wonderful
[__] six minute piece from celebration
uh Star Wars celebration over in the UK go watch
that but while he's gone [__] dilf man is all
over this [__] dilfman's gonna give us some
questions dilfman take it away this show has been
going on for a thousand hours now I don't want
to say it feels that way what time do we start uh
after my imposed delays I think about 6 10 6 13
maybe so so it's been over three hours and yeah
and we're nowhere close to stopping because now
we've got the Q a anybody else in the audience but
I've been having a good ass [__] time tonight
man like I miss all this [__] when we didn't do
it for a few weeks I was [__] fiending man
for a fix now we're [__] pop culture junk
so you ready all right oh I want to teach
you about our show a little more yes it's
your show uh the dorky review show who was our
super janitor that contributed wonderful ten
dollars thank you so much ask the question if
Marvel gave Mark and Kevin the Reigns to write
a Multiverse scene in the next Deadpool where
Deadpool and Wolverine land in the DC Universe
verse for a bit what iconic scenes or characters
would you have them interact with so it's in the
DC Universe yes but still in a Deadpool movie
with Wolverine so Deadpool 3 mythical scene
what what Infamous scene do you have them
drop in from the comics or what characters
do you have them go with my first instinct is Bane
breaking Batman [Music] so that Deadpool can make
fun of [__] Batman for getting his back broken
something that you know [__] Deadpool can't be
[__] killed as we've seen over and over again so
I think there's humor to be mine there uh my next
spot would be uh flash on the cosmic tread Bill
the treadmill tread pill treadmill in [__] uh
crisis and my next [__] scene would be doomsday
spoilers doomsday kill Superman 20-year spoilers
uh I'd have him jump in on that scene those are
three you only asked for one I gave you three mark
um I I feel like I want Deadpool and Wolverine to
drop in on uh a sound of her wings in the Sandman
just to talk about how [__] mopey dream is
like look at this [__] pale ghost what's
your big what's your damage dude and then
to have Logan get to talk to death about
I won't die yeah you will no I won't
haven't done it yet been live for 400
years not gonna die anytime soon [__]
you [__] you Thin White Duke [__] you
um they're a Crime Alley I think Crime Alley is
just waiting for humor oh my God what an excellent
[__] pull how many jokes they can make about
those [__] pearls excellent pull excellent poll
right there because that's one of the most solemn
moments in DC history responsible for giving us
one of the most solemn [__] heroes in the world
yes you're absolutely right it's ripe for parody
yeah what's that kid so [__] sad about I don't
know that was Hispanics maybe maybe he's just
a sad [__] kid maybe he killed them hey kid
did you kill those two people or just happened
be like why didn't you [__] kill the guy that
killed your parents yeah it's [__] nut up kid
[Music]
oh your mother's dead oh sorry about that
cheer up Cheer Up Charlie thank you [Laughter]
um before delfman comes back uh somebody said
uh Kalyn baby and Chad said did you talk about
Michael Lerner we did not the great Michael
Lerner passed away um what a wonderful actor
he was and many wonderful roles including John
hamburg's safe man where he played big fats but
I believe he [__] won an Oscar or at least was
nominated for Barton Fink if I'm correct which
still to this day remains one of my favorite
performances of all time his [__] moments
in the sun in [__] Barton Fink are phenomenal
when I saw that he passed away instantly I went
to YouTube and watched all of his scenes in
Barton thing him is the head of the studio
he's the one that's like we all have we all want
that Barton Fink feeling but I assume you have
it in Spades because you're him and his life
where he's like because I've got Horse Sense
God damn it Showmanship oh he's so fantastic
he's the writer's King at Capital pictures uh
a wonderful performer and a wonderful performance
but yes he passed away damn nominated for fake
but did not nominate thank you he should have
[__] won Not only was he [__] nominated and
should have won best supporting they should have
given him best actor he's so good in that go to
YouTube enter Barton Fink Michael Lerner and
watch those scenes it's just a [__] Clinic
on Fast talking comedic performance is wonderful
he will be missed uh tough man come on back still
okay thank you that's wonderful I'm not giving my
answer because I don't have enough reference you
know all of my stuff is I would just literally
have them fall into any Random episode of the
Super Friends that's what I would do you know what
not bad not bad considering that you're [__] you
know not as armed as the rest of us with this
nonsense not bad as you can see there's an Iron
Man there's a Spider-Man there's a Captain America
shield so you know where [__] Will's heart is
you don't go deep on DC that's
a good pull right there man well
this is what happens when you get your uh
your bamf man off wish that's all I'll say
uh okay you ready for the next question
yes suddenly went into game show mode uh
Z Howard 1992 asked uh if you had the
cupboard from Indian in the Cupboard
what childhood toys of yours would you
put in it and how would they interact
wow that is a great question what an excellent
goal um if I go like this and you never see this
part of the room and [__] like that like there's
a big giant naked portrait of my wife over there
and stuff um on this shelf right there over here
are all pieces of my [__] childhood [__] that
like I used to own as a kid and still own as
an adult that came directly from my childhood
in 21 Jackson Street so I'm gonna look at this
shelf and tell you what it would be okay I got
a McDonald's Playland said um it wasn't by fish I
think Fisher Price made it or maybe it was a place
called I forget who made it but it wasn't the
round old Fisher Price figures and [__] these
were square and the there was one of them you know
one of the came with like uh it was at McDonald's
and it has the big sign and inside you can move
the fast food trays the trays with stickers of
the fast food and [__] and the McDonald workers
are represented by wearing individuals they don't
wear hats anymore at McDonald's as we all know
and stuff but that figure the one of them I I
you know I'll grab it it was called I called the
figure my little man you know how like kids carry
a blanket like they're silky or they're [__]
uh what do they call that [__] like [__]
nubby no [__] was it when you when you call
like a security blanket like linuses you're
wubsy like a wooby like a woman that was the
word I was searching for this McDonald Land
figure which I'll go grab when um you know uh
Mark does his answer and [__] uh was my [__]
whoopie and I took it everywhere and the thing
is it became so worn that the head could come
off of it very easily but then I turned him into
the Invisible Man because like you could [__]
make him Invisible by his head comes off and then
[__] the body goes away and [__] like that
um I would bring my little man to life I know
everyone's thinking about my dick no that's
not what my little man is it's this figure
from my McDonald lands playset now this is
not the original McDonald's playset that [__]
probably went in the garbage years ago thank you
mother I went and bought one of these online so I
could re-buy a piece of my childhood and [__] I
said look Disney can't have it all and so I went
and bought this mcdonaldland's playset and so it
sits on my shelf uh more indicative of my youth
not an actual [__] Remnant from my youth um I
would I would bring my little I put my little man
in the cupboard I'd bring my little man to life
and we'd be best friends again just like we were
in my childhood the other thing I'd grab probably
uh they made this remember the SST things where
you pull it back oh yeah launch it I got a series
of Snoopy ssts man from childhood um I was a
big peanuts fan and remain a big peanuts fan
um and I played this thing forever Snoopy
became my next little man I would carry that
around because you could take a rubber Snoopy put
him in the [__] motorcycle it had some of the
motorcycles broke apart and [__] like that I'd
[__] bring that [__] to life number one me
and Snoopy would finally be friends in real life
number two Snoopy drove a motorcycle and some of
them had side cars and I would happily sit next
to a motorcycle driving Snoopy this is the man
who flew the SOP with camel when I say man I mean
dog um so I would do that and then for a third
oh my God Weebles Weebles wobble but they
don't fall down that's right Mark remembers
um I'd bring a Weeble to life and [__] like
that uh because I love [__] Weebles I had
the Jaws game you know we put [__] in his
mouth and he pitch pull [__] off and then
it Chomps your clothes and [__] and that's how
you lose so I would play jaws with because they
didn't have Jaws action figures back in the
day but they did have this Jaws game but my
three Weebles one was Captain Quint that was the
pirate Weeble uh one was uh [__] the guy who
just had the W on her shirt and [__] that
was my uh Brody Chief Brody Weeble and then
there was one who had glasses that was my Matt
Hooper Weebles so I bring those Weebles to life
man they they years later they made different
Weebles which don't look like the real Weebles
as far as I'm concerned those are the three Man
Mark you go and I'm gonna go grab my [__] uh
I'm afraid that I don't have nearly as uh tied
a bond to my childhood toys the way Kev does
um I mean I the the first real toys toys that
I remember getting were Star Wars figures
um Star Wars and GI Joe I was never uh you know
perished the thought I was never a huge He-Man
guy I mean I had a few He-Man figures but I was
never um that was not the one that I went deep on
I think I went dude you wrote [__] on a
goddamn He-Man show you better say he-man
we were actually too old for He-Man yeah He-Man
just it missed me you know in that in that sort
of demographic Zone I was not that kid I wanted
the toys but my parents were like we did Star
Wars we're not starting a whole other [__] thing
for you yeah you are done now yes but I think if I
could put anything in in the in the cupboard and
have it come to life and then roll around with me
pocket-sized because they're not gonna be like
[__] life-sized they're this big he said they
would put Snake Eyes from uh from GI Joe in there
because who couldn't use a pocket-sized ninja
like just to solve problems man like it's like
my bodyguard but in your pocket it doesn't say
a lot but you can talk to and it's just nod
it's like yeah man like no I get you I feel
you like yeah you just you're mute that's okay
um but I can slice anybody you need me to slice
um so yeah I go I go I go snake eyes
that's a [__] Weeble that's a Weeble right
there kids and that's the [__] that was the
Weeble who played Roy Scheider in my version of
Jaws this is the Snoopy SST cycle this one don't
break apart so he's got Woodstock in the back but
the Snoopy actually comes out and stuff he's got
like a bottom so you could work him like a finger
puppet if your fingers are very small like a child
legless Snoopy so if you go like this it's
all good you go like this it's horrifying
but he you put him in the cycle and [__]
and then you [__] yank it back and you turn
the handle and you press the click and it went
across the floor and [__] this though is not my
original little man but this is what the little
man looked like wow if his head could come off
this one's secured [__] but I pick his head off
and I pretend he was the Invisible Man this [__]
and again not this exact one my real little man
is lost to the ages but a little man that looked
exactly like this spent so much time in my hand
as a child and shout out to my brother Donald
we were at my uh grandparents house
in Edison New Jersey was it Edison
no I think my it wasn't where where was it
Hillside at the hillside that's what it is um past
whatever [__] now I'm deep in the weeds of New
Jersey but in any event we're at my grandparents
house and by the staircase up to my grandparents
house was a tiny [__] crevice where the wall met
the [__] doorway and [__] and he fit into this
[__] crevice and my brother you know this is
gonna ain't gonna make anybody [__] laugh but I
this would make me cry laughter as a child and I'm
talking five years old my brother would put him
in that little crevice and he would sing I'm in
my little corner of the world and oh my God that
was the funniest thing ever so have you ever liked
clerks or [__] Mall Rats or any of the comedies
I ever did it begins with my brother singing I'm
in my little corner of the world with my little
man right there he's meant to be wearing a hat
kids because back in the day McDonald's employees
wore little hats like that technology yeah
what a [__] wonderful walk down memory lane that
was for me I know a bunch of people were like good
God but yeah BJ Fisher in chat mentioned the Six
Million Dollar Man toy which I remember like I had
one of those with the little discs that you could
slide in his [__] head into well his bionics
were in his arm you could take the bionics off
you could look through the eye and the hole in
the back of his head for a bionic Wyatt had a
magnifying eye and [__] and his arm would go
click click click click came with a motor engine
like the engine of a [__] car that he could lift
up and stuff and he had roll down skin to cover
his bionics yep I had all those [__] dolls man
I had Six Million Dollar Man I had Oscar Goldman
and the exploding briefcase at the rocket that
[__] you could do operations on [__] Six
Million Dollar Man and yes I had Jamie Summers
man of course I've loved it all that's dedication
see Mark stole my thunder because I was gonna say
I would put my Six Million Dollar Man in there
and then the only other thing I would put in well
probably my GI joke because that poor thing went
through hell and back he deserves a chance to live
and interact with other things but the last thing
I would put in this nobody's gonna know these but
my dad used to work for the company that made
heavy construction equipment Komatsu so he would
always go away on a business trip or when they
would get new models their little die-cast models
of their older units he would be able to bring
them home for me so I would put them in there so
that way they could be a little mechanical Army
for The Bionic Man and and GI Joe with one leg
and and drawing all over his head I just know if
they came to life though they would just judge me
they were like why dilf man pretty much this
is what you became we had such hope for you
somebody mentioned in chat that is uh and
endless music said Planet of the Apes was my jam
shout out to every Migo doll ever made if I had
a joker Migo doll I wanted I had a general erko
or ursus Amigo doll I wanted [__] all the Migo
dolls but like generally any mego doll I had was a
hand me down or something I found in the garbage
yes I was a garbage picker um but man oh man uh
the Migo owned my childhood they had the defining
toys because we all grew up on reruns of Batman
and Robin and those were the main Migos anyways
he ain't lying just man ain't lying kids excellent
um all right last question last question well
we'll see if it's last because Super Chat might
[__] pay to ask a question everybody
else that was spending money fell asleep
I'm gonna get talked to later uh Adam hold on
man Brian Christian chat said Tonka toy trucks
that's for the rich kids I remembered
a commercial it's a Tonka toy attack a
toy built Tonka Strong build
Tonka tough just for fun fun
part of my [__] childhood as well I had a couple
tongues but I wouldn't put them in the cupboard
because then you just get a small truck no magic
there which is a tiny truck without a driver
well now I gotta ask you know what I put in that
cupboard my dead father he said he could come back
I put that urn in the closet and then he'd be like
let me the [__] out where's the rest of me I'd
be like in an urn that looks like dolphin's Dad
too long to explain but there's some dignity here
stick a Monchichi in there and just ask
it why do you exist wow what a deep cut
that is oh so soft and cuddly yeah see
look a bunch of never mind we got we
got Jingles kids When We Were Young we
didn't just have toys we had Jingles
so if you couldn't afford the toys
you could at least sing the jingles
uh Adam kimmelman from the chat asked
you're tasked to read make The Odd
Couple but with genre characters who's
your neat freak feeling well we know who
the people are but who's your Felix
singer and who's your Oscar Madison
so Felix has to be fastidious
and Oscar has to be kind of like a slob
well I mean I guess Todd McFarland did it
with Sam and twitch right they kind of fit
that mold but let's see who would be mine
Linus Van Pelt would be my Felix
um pig pen oh my oscar I'd go right to the [__]
peanuts kids right to those depressed peanuts
children it was Depression era urchins I just I
was talking I think I was talking to my brother
about it when I was back in Florida but I was
like it's crazy to me that [__] the peanuts
aren't as big now as when we were children
because now kids are really depressed like
you know Charles Schultz was a middle-aged man
or you know at least an adult when he was doing
little folks and like all these stories about
like [__] the first I don't know who I was
talking about I'm John Gordon I think my friend
first time I ever heard the term psychiatric
was [__] from the peanuts and that was I
was like six years old I was like how do you
pronounce this word my sister was like psychiatric
I was like what does that mean she's like that's a
head doctor for people who are crazy and you know
Charles Schultz was like way ahead of his time in
terms of like he drew cute characters but they
were sassy as [__] one of the first the first
strip of Little Folks which is what became peanuts
in the home of Charlie Brown there's a there's a I
forget which characters are sitting there and
like Derek Here Comes Charlie Brown good old
Charlie Brown there's Charlie Brown and the
last panel was the kids going God I hate him
shit's dark very dark so I choose Lions Van Pelt
and I choose Pig Pen only because a it works and B
because I'm gonna try to keep peanuts love alive
man did you ever see uh it was the thing that
swept the internet for all of half an hour like
five or six years ago but it was Garfield without
Garfield yeah just like pulled Garfield out of
just John having existential crises standing over
the kitchen saying things to nothing expressing
things to nothing yes oh my God that was wonderful
boy that pulls me back to the early days of the
internet there was also it was like peanuts minus
one where they would always pull the last frame
out of peanuts so we just give you the three
panels set up but not the joke at the end and
then it's just a bunch of sad depressed children
as an old-time peanuts fan that sounds good
strong strong word um I think I go with uh with
heck McCoy as your Felix Unger and uh and Logan
as your your mat your Oscar Madison I think it's
beast and Wolverine but Beast is the neat freak
Beast is a fastidious one and then Wolverine
just has [__] beard cans everywhere and just
[__] in the woods he doesn't care excellent
[__] in the woods when is he [__] [__] in
the woods I mean it wouldn't surprise me if he had
cut out of Logan what are you doing Logan
[__] in the woods man I don't know
excellent [__] pull good times on that um
um and enlist music said what is the Fat Man
on Batman runtime record or fat man Beyond
rather runtime record I don't know question
definitely three hours we've done three
hours before we've done three apps we've
done three hours like standing at the bar
um ooh this is two dollars in super
chat but it's [__] worth talking about
recovery unplugged says hi Kevin I'm a mental
health advocate uh so am I in a big bad way
um more now than I've ever been in my
life but more on that later in the coming
weeks or if you want to join that Kevin
Smith Club you can hear some meditations
oh my God you're amazing thank you for helping me
[__] sell that if you join that Kevin Smith club
kids which is like my patreon or whatever the
[__] I used to do a show called wake and bake
there because I smoke weed and would smoke weed
and [__] Chit Chat uh but since I don't smoke
weed anymore um I I felt like calling it wake
and bake was weird and then for a while I was
like well we could change it to this we could
change it to that uh but as of this morning I
launched wake and bake is finished last episode
I did was me talking about my mom being in the
hospital and [__] uh but now the show is called
meditations uh where we talk about mental health
amongst other things and whatnot uh you can join
that Kevin Smith club and watch that show all you
want it's on Mondays Wednesdays and Fridays
and in a world where you're [__] overpaying
for Super Chat my God go join that Kevin Smith
club's way cheaper and you'll get answers fast
um is that is that it I mean I mean unless
you're gonna suddenly try and invoke the Super
Chat gods and Rise raise them what happens to the
super chatters that like went away like that we
some a donkey show the donkey
that dorky review show says
why did Kevin stop smoking weed I missed
that episode I've talked about it before
um especially right here um it's too long to go
into but long story short you know I've just uh
I'd like to be present and weed was wonderful
for 15 years straight but it allowed me to be
present while not being present at all and now
I just wanna be present Nico gave us 53.90 of
some currency which I don't recognize just
to give us a goddamn thumbs up [__] a man
to answer your question Kevin I can I can
show you a different interface that you
can work from where you can see all of
them I'm looking at them all right now
is that right yeah man how come I don't have
that because you're scared of new things
you ain't wrong because that's why there's a
clerks three as opposed to like anything new
yeah I don't I don't got any Super Chatters man I
used to although Josh mundahl just jumped in once
again Josh spent like 500 tonight don't do that
Josh he says but we cannot have a direct chat
with you on the club side Kevin so this is the
direct way to communicate with you and Mark my
brother he's right but you can have a direct chat
with me because now I'm going to start going into
the what's it called will the Discord thank you
will oh you got a Discord yeah he's got it all
club members can go to the Discord and there
is an AKA channel in there so ask Kev anything
and will is going to teach me how to use the
Discord so I could [__] jump in there and
and play you seem to teach you but really it's
just like here log in here click this go it's
it's it's nothing man well I I don't [__] learn
from Reading will I I need to be taught a [__]
thing told the thing by a person it's case in
point I ain't read a [__] book in years you
could tell by my language that must be the case
you know what I just note I just discovered no
[__] wait hold on hold on I have personally
sold advertising space on this podcast
I know I just never listen to them I listen to
my own audiobook once when I recorded it and
[__] and they sent it to me it's like all
right that sounds like me but Scott Moser uh
was like you know what book you've got
to read uh the courage to be disliked
is that what the title is hold on I
want to say it I want to get it right
it's called the courage to be disliked
and it's written by uh [__] I can't oh
shishimi is that right close
enough yeah good enough and
fumataki Koga um the Japanese phenomenon
that shows you how to change your life
and Achieve real happiness so you know Mojo's like
you should read this and I'm like bro you know me
I'm [__] I never got time to read a goddamn book
and [__] like that that's never gonna happen and
he's like why don't you just listen to it and I
was like a [__] newfangled listen to they've
only had books on tape for the last like [__]
40 years and [__] so I I [__] joined Audible
and I'm you know I go hiking running every day and
I'm in the car a lot I always listen to the same
100 [__] songs over and over and over again now
all of a sudden I'm listening to this book I'm on
chapter [__] 30. like this is amazing I know
it's a free commercial for audible but [__]
it I'm loving the [__] out of this book the
courage to be just like and I don't know if you
can say I've read a book anymore if somebody says
it to you but I'm learning can you yeah account
so I could be like I read it even though I didn't
you ingested the content of the book good enough
for me man um the Rob Brown Channel says Kevin
Smith writer discovers books I've been busy making
[__] so I stopped reading [__] and whatnot but
this gives me a chance to like go hiking and not
[__] listen to the same 100 songs over and over
again now I'm [__] listening to this book and
there's something oddly comforting about somebody
reading a book and I also cognize a lot better
somebody's saying [__] to me rather than me
reading it most of the [__] I would read would
just be lost on me and [__] and now instead I'm
[__] I can rewind it and be like what did they
[__] say this book has taught me so many good
things man the courage to be disliked so yes I'm
I don't know how I got started on this thread but
I don't either but I I will also say that most of
the books that I have quote unquote read for the
last five years or so have been audiobooks is
that right yeah because I'm in the car a lot and
like I used to listen to lots of podcasts but like
people will send me books like hey do you want to
like maybe think about adapting this you're gonna
take a run at this or I wrote a book or whatever
it is it's like great and download it right away
and start listening to it because when I had a
train commute on the East Coast I used to read
a lot but without a train and just in my car that
was just dead time and so that's become the way I
like begin to ingest [__] and he's the smartest
guy on this [__] show kids we all know that so
if Mark [__] advocates for listening to a book
then God damn it listening to a book we shall
um I've been loving it believe me this ain't
the last book I'm going to listen to now I'm
going to listen to more books because that's how
I [__] learn you're an auditory learner not a
visual learner see if I was the smartest guy
in the show I would have said that 10 minutes
uh Josh munshall paid 999 stop [__] paying
money Josh to say this oh by the way for God
in Jersey He-Man was the bomb yo Transcendental
Meditation will help a lot with mental health
and happiness sobriety is a daily Choice
you've got more support than you realize
that's very [__] sweet thank you recovery
unplugged jump back into 10 bucks and say this
is Amy will you be able to be at my letters
to Daniel screening it's my castle May 19th
7 PM she's gonna get a free commercial out of
this um Amy did this uh uh flip called letters
to Daniel which she's bringing to smog
Castle as you heard on May 19th uh 7 P.M
why let me check my calendar Amy well not let
me agree she spent 30 bucks overall the shape
May 19th I believe I may be there I believe I may
be there Amy um letters to Daniel kids come see
it it's modcastle Cinemas at May 19th tickets
that's my castlecinemas.com uh and good seeing
you again Amy but don't don't we know each other
don't [__] pay me to ask what to say things
especially to say nice things like that um Keith
says with super chats we will be here five hours
I don't think uh I don't think anyone wants
that so what we should wrap up I think we should
although Corey Gilmartin just spent five
bucks to say this hey Kev had a blast at
the John Wick 4 screening at smodcast of last
Saturday he was there to watch quick with Kev
thanks for staying after to talk with me
and Katie uh so hype for Guardians 3 and
4 20. yeah man when is Guardians open
uh May 40th yeah first weekend in May
May 4th I gotta see if I'm gonna be there for that
because I definitely want to [__] do that like
that's how we get to do the merry Marvel movie
Society since I can't show the old [__] you
gotta do there and [__] if that have you seen
that little piece they put up online the like
you know [__] uh bunch of the cast sitting there
talking about like how this is the end and [__]
you know it's like interview footage mixed with
the trailer all of them [__] talk about like
bring tissues man like it's all [__] heart in
this one around I can't wait I want James Gunn to
make me cry so badly you can call me a masochist I
don't give a [__] yeah oh no [__] the trailer
makes me emotion well may the fourth you're there
for revenge of the Smith that's all I can tell you
and when does when does this open May
4th oh [__] so I'm gonna be there
uh apparently so guess what we'll be adding
to the schedule guess what your community
I will be flying there um Guardians of the Galaxy
the same as Star Wars Day says Brian Christian in
chat there you go I'll be there for that [__]
man can't wait I saw a trailer at um San Diego
Comic-Con last year when they did the [__] you
know marvel panel and [__] which they've never
released one to The Flaming Lips do you realize
was like one of my favorite things I've ever seen
in my [__] life um that made it very emotional
but [__] every trailer they've put together
since you've been gone [__] trailer like I can't
wait James Gunn gonna make gonna make us all cry
and I'm here for it uh kids have you enjoyed does
Kev know that YouTube takes a cut of Super Chat
says they told me earlier in the [__] in the
broadcast man I mean what you're going does it
matter yes excellent point dilfman it's free
money kids for those who hate my films don't
worry I'm gonna give up filmmaking because this
Super Chat [__] that's where my future lies
answered questions for money that's what I used
to do q and A's for Years anyway so now we just
get to do it from home uh thank you for all
you super Chatters who came and threw money
at us and [__] like that uh we can afford to
pay people like will Wilkins dilfman himself
thanks to your large yes um thanks for everyone
else even the people that didn't [__] pay for
Super Chat and you don't have to pay for Super
Chat kids um I'm sure when this show is done I'm
gonna get talked to by a hundred people who are
like stop it and I do bad idea yeah you're gonna
kill the show and I said we killed the show a long
time ago nobody's coming they're coming for Austin
is that right we have Austin alone he's my boy
that's my son for God's sakes and actually as
he pointed out uh because he texted me be like
don't [__] credit me with Super Chat the one
who credited the one who deserves the credit for
me knowing about Super Chat was my kid who paid
Peter sharetta and his [__] Disney you know his
I love Disney show him and his lady I don't know
what it's called I'm not doing it justice but
she told me she was like I paid ten dollars to
ask a question on Super Chat and I was like wait a
second what and she described what it is and I was
like you can do this [__] now and so today in
Austin is Harley who introduced me to Super Chat
um there it is kids did you enjoy yourselves
I [__] had a good ass time if we keep this
going for another 10 minutes it'll be
a four hour [__] show I can't do it
Jason just gave us five bucks in Super Chat
to say I just got clerks three the ending
got me teary eyed boy thank you I've been living
with for months now people on Twitter uh saying
respectfully [__] you uh because I made them
emotional with uh clerks three uh you're welcome
uh have you enjoyed yourselves as much as I did
well if you did is because of the guy [__]
I never do it right the guy right there kids I
[__] without the smartest man on [__] or woman
on [__] fat man beyond kids is Mark Bernard this
show ain't nothing without the great Mark madard
and give it up for Mark Bernard and everybody
thank you everybody um and uh this week my God
proving that [__] he don't know [__] about
Star Wars like [__] Banff man but God damn it
if he didn't produce the [__] out of this show
uh give it up for [__] dilf man dilf in here
hello thank you I appreciate it I'm just ladies
and gentlemen I'm very sales oriented I guess
rightfully so somebody got to be speaking of sales
kids are you in Los Angeles come see me and Mark
Bernardin no no no no me and Mark Bernard when we
figure out when that show is going to be but this
Saturday come see me Ralph Garmin doing Hollywood
Babylon you want to see me and Mark Bernard in New
Jersey you go to smartcastlecinemas.com right now
go to the coming soon section tickets on sale for
the August what is it 25th August 25th fat man
beyond and on August 26th there may or may not
be keep calm and Curry on but it's on sale now so
I don't know what the [__] Ernie's talking about
um come see us for heaven's sakes come to smog
Castle Cinemas I'm coming there all throughout
the next few weeks man don't forget 420 Jane Sal
and Bob reboot 421 trailer park 422 is sold out
it's Chasing Amy with Jason Lee and then revenge
of the Smith on May 5th but I'm going to be there
now for [__] May 4th for Guardians of the [__]
Galaxy and [__] like that watch that with Keb
um uh what else are we doing May 6th is uh Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back with Jason Muse May 7th is
drawing flies with Malcolm Ingram and Jason Muse
May 28th is [__] Jersey Girl the the Snyder cut
what what the [__] what's IDR
50 000 what [__] what Indonesian
50 000 we're Rich I just wanted to be like
rupals we could quit the show fifty thousand
eight cat fan from Indonesia here when are we
going to get the continuation of the Batman
movie commentaries they're hilarious what a
great question yeah 50 000 whatever that is
you're gonna get a goddamn answer when will
it be Mark uh it could be whenever you want
it to be Kim I think all we have to do is
uh we had Dark Knight and Dark Knight Rises
and then we're done is that right and then the
Batman if we want to go all the way through
I'm sorry did that did you guys see my face I mean
how about how about we'll do the first two hours
of the Batman but then like there's a flood out
of nowhere like [Music] yes the Sandman comes
in and pulls them off oh deep Cuts wonderful
um no somebody Warrior fellas that somebody really
just gave away 50k uh no because as Roberto Hoyas
points out it's 3.36 but still that 50 000 was
an impressive looking [__] number um kids
there you go you wanted some fat man beyond
you got it and it wouldn't [__] stop at all
uh 336 3.36 seconds 36 Cents that's what that
fifty thousand IDR number is we don't give a
[__] money's money and money no YouTube
took 30 of that but I don't give a [__]
and this went long strong because
we're down to get the friction on
Baby Got Back
uh there it is kids [__] uh we'll be
back uh with episodes what is it three
three and four hundred you better bet that
episode 400 is going to happen in the next
two weeks and it's gonna happen at [__]
scum and villainy cantina and then the only
question is whether 399 is an in-person show
or a [__] one of these things but now that
[__] Super Chat exists I'm never going back to
the [__] 401 to 500 is back on the Super Chat
Mark ain't lying man don't don't don't don't
be shocked if I just do a whole ass Super Chat
Show Kevin Super Chat a love story and just
everybody want to create a podcast called Kev
Super Chat and that's all we're gonna do throw me
a shekel throw me a [__] two bits throw me 50
000 of whatever that was for 3.36 and I'll
answer your goddamn question awesome coin to
your Smither yeah uh there it is
my friends uh for fat man beyond
um I'm Kevin Smith and I am Mark Bernard
tune in next time same Super Chat Time same
Super Chat Channel podcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith a super chatty Jeff's kiss to you all
right this is the cat greetings
everybody and welcome to the AKA
ask Kevin it's all well at the end of the show
Bob get old off Kevin Smith foreign